once this whole thing falls apart and we
are climbing the Kudzu vines that spiral
up the Sears Tower like they say in
Fight Club Bobby will go back to his
gatherer form and be happy as a pig and
[ __ ] just walking around the loincloth
with his bird hanging out tracking jokes
to people and climbing up on them for a
stool lap dance or whatever he does you
think some level of crazy is required
for comedy yeah like at some point yes
have there been low points in your life
uh yeah I know yeah yeah hey yeah
hahaha
the following is a conversation with
Will Sasso a comedian actor podcaster
and someone I've been a fan of for many
years since Mad TV in the late 90s to
recently with the time in the podcast
and now the new podcast called dudesy
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's will
Sasso
so let's call it the elephant in the
room
you wore a black suit in a recent
episode of doozy yes
you wore a black suit again today uh
Shakespeare than Mark Twain said clothes
make the man
uh what kind of man does a suit make you
well me in particular it makes me a
fellow who did not get this dry cleaned
in between because that episode of the
show as we sit here now was around a
week ago
so that's that's the kind of man it
makes me well the uh the nice things
you're wearing pants I think yes I am
wearing I don't think you were wearing
pants in the episode that's correct I I
prefer to wear shorts but this was a
special occasion so I'm wearing pants
and I thought it fitting obviously to
just wear you know the black tie and uh
clothes do make them in and I'm uh I I
would not consider myself to be a man of
leisure but I do enjoy shorts because my
legs get hot
so that's what kind of man the shorts
make often do you wear a suit I [ __ ]
hate wearing suits so what is this a
statement of uh is it ironic or is it
are you honoring the gods of this
particular podcast I'm honoring the gods
of this particular podcast would be a
good way to put it yes no this is this
is in in reverence of and in dedication
to you and our newfound friendship here
yes which we are uh making uh on the
podcast you and I just met yeah
everything that we're saying here is the
or the first things that we're saying to
each other so I'm meeting you on Common
Ground
dressed like well I've been actually a
one-way friend of yours for many many
years since Mad TV oh
um when did you start on mentee so that
was many I mean in 90s 97 yeah 97. so I
was a huge fan of yours and the cast was
incredible it's one of the funniest
shows ever created your whole journey
watching through that was was incredible
for Mad TV to Three Stooges to the
podcast
the the 10 minute pause and then the new
podcast is incredible
um cheers my favorite role that you
played was the mountain in the Game of
Thrones what was it like working with
Dragons well the dragons are usually
tennis balls on the end of c-stands but
uh sometimes they they hang out
um I am c-stand it's like you know it's
like a little like the thing you got the
camera on here oh this is like film
lingo yeah no I understand I'm trying to
impress you with my film lingo you know
what a banana is yeah and you walk like
this oh do a banana I take it back I did
not know what a banana was yeah
yeah because it's just a food yeah
normally uh I can see Hollywood folk the
lingo and I'm uh my name is Bjorn hap
Thor bjornsson and I am seven foot four
and uh yeah so dragons don't dragons
don't scare me even though they've been
extinct for a while these scientists
right is that check out yeah I actually
I'm really into video games I don't know
if you play video games there's a
there's a Skyrim
uh video game that's part of the Elder
Scroll series and for the longest time
there's a legend that there's dragons I
think it's starting in Daggerfall and so
I always I grew up playing those video
games and dreaming of one day meeting a
dragon in a virtual world and eventually
you did in in Skyrim so it's
dragons represent I don't know exactly
what they represent but they represent
maybe this kind of mythical creature
that is bigger than anything humans can
comply possibly comprehend maybe because
they're so they're so they show up so
often in myth from the from the
religious stories you know of the snake
and so on The Serpent and I don't know
what that is with this breathing fire
that's kind of weird it's interesting
when I think about dragons because uh
now that you bring it up these are
people that probably wouldn't have
access to the fact that there used to be
dinosaurs right maybe they did if they
didn't they're drawing things that look
like you know a dinosaur cousin but cool
that can breathe fire and has Wacky
Wings and a spiked tail
um yeah where the heck did they come up
with that because they're clearly of
course represented in mythology all the
way back to uh
no not cave drawings well the Egyptians
probably knew what the and they could
time travel so they would have gone back
to the caves with the aliens that placed
living organisms on Earth
could time travel and they could plant
Legends into the into the collective
intelligence of the human species yeah
and perhaps they were thinking of us to
do something smart with it and we didn't
we just came up with Skyrim now we're
just what's that sorry that was very
offensive I'm sorry I don't mean offend
you with your video game I'm more of a
burger a burger time uh Donkey Kong dude
oh what is that that's an original
burger time was an arcade game that
later showed up on the in television
um uh who's in television I believe it
was made by Texas Instruments horrible
first generation uh video game console
and burger time you just it's like Super
Mario you just gotta stay away from the
the eggs and the pickles and stuff and
you just go and you the bun Falls and
then you go down to then wait in the
cheese and then the meat I'm not going
to say it's as complicated as Skyrim but
uh took me a while to finish it when I
was seven
did you play video games that was that a
part of your life a part of this source
of happiness for you at all it was it
was I played video games up until around
uh I think in 2010 I got the red ring of
death on my Xbox 360. that was it that
was it I never or whatever the Xbox was
then yeah I had I was playing uh I had
finished uh the the Grand Theft Auto
that was out and finished the Red Dead
Redemption so I was doing that thing
where you just drive around uh you know
the streets of New York or just ride
around on your horse shooting people and
uh you know throwing grenades into into
groups of people in uh Grand Theft and
you're describing the same thing that
happened a decade later because it's now
Red Dead Redemption 2 and there's still
not a new Grand Theft Auto so yeah there
isn't right yeah they're working on it
they're always flirting with that idea
you know who else plays Skyrim
another person the two people I'm a huge
fan of from that time in Mad TV's Bobby
League he plays Skyrim he's a huge fan
he plays every so what Bobby Lee loves
to do
is the grind do the boring task over and
over gather mushroom like in Skyrim you
can fight dragons you can fight all
kinds of things but you can also gather
mushrooms and different ingredients to
make potions and all that kind of he
loves the ingredients that he's the you
know in the hunter-gatherer World he's
The Gatherer he's The Gatherer yeah I've
heard him described that way and and he
likes to describe himself that way uh I
worked with Bobby not too long ago he
came and did a couple days on this thing
we were shooting and uh I was looking
forward to catching up with my old pal
and if you know anything about Bobby Lee
you'd probably be able to predict that
he spent that entire time playing
farming on his iPad all humans are a
source of anxiety and trouble so
sometimes it's good to escape human
interaction through video games totally
I'm with him on that he's he's one of
the funniest people ever what what do
you think is uh what do you think makes
him funny it's just all the times you've
worked with him the the
non-standard non-secular way of his
being
Bobby Lee is one of the most Raw people
raw performers who lets it all hang out
to the degree that he will even get
naked in front of his audience which is
usually a metaphor for someone doing
stand-up I'm bearing all yeah I'm
showing you everything and Bobby will
just uh pull his bird out of his pants
yeah I don't think he understands
metaphor too much he embodies metaphor
yes he embodies metaphor he's The Gather
we call him the Gathering metaphor Bobby
The Gatherer metaphor he's a metaphor
for something else for somebody else's
life someday he'll be in the dictionary
yeah representing some kind of concept
maybe the metaphor itself yeah once once
this whole thing falls apart and we are
climbing the Kudzu Vines uh that spiral
up the Sears Tower like they say in
Fight Club Bobby will go back to his
gatherer form and be happy as a pig and
[ __ ] just walking around in a loin cloth
with his bird hanging out cracking jokes
to people and climbing up on them for a
stool lap dance or whatever I'd love to
dig into something he he did you guys
did a lot of good podcasts together he
asked you in a very uncomfortable
process of why you don't do stand-up so
let me ask you
do you hate money
well I'm originally from Canada yeah so
I'm uh I'm yeah I'm I'm a freaking Pinko
uh socialist is that what uh where you
come from that's not a nice thing to say
I thought the Soviet Union that is a
nice thing to say like I call someone
right comrade yeah it's a good he's a
good socialist yeah he has red
like bold colors yeah yeah there's an
interesting tension in your voice and
the way you talked about it there's just
not a source of happiness for you you
you respect the art form but it was not
something that you were connected to you
felt connected to that's a good way to
put it yeah I I respect the art form uh
a lot I and I grew up with all the
albums and stuff I had an older brother
and sister who so I you know we had the
we had George Carlin we had uh you know
Richard Pryor we had Robert Klein we had
Guild alive the Gilda Radner uh concert
we had we had all sorts of stuff but you
know I don't know there's a lot of
there's a lot of reasons I do feel like
a career in Show Business
it is you know they it never goes the
way you plan uh like most things and I
was fortunate enough to get started
outside of my native Vancouver or in my
native Vancouver I grew up in The Burbs
outside and there was a lot of Industry
there so I was fortunate enough to get
started as an actor when I was like 16
so
there there yeah there was there were
some times early on where I came up with
some stand-up stuff and did it but uh
yeah I quickly abandoned it and then
you know you go through you do Mad TV
and stuff and then and that's where my
and this is gonna sound weird do I sound
as anxietal as I did when I was on
Bobby's podcast trying to avoid his
questions
well he was giving you this face this
whole time that was making
the whole just atmosphere feel full of
anxiety so I'm trying not to give you a
face the whole time I was saying play
cool play cool yeah okay uh play
collects play cool you said it out loud
a couple times I did just you know you
cut that out okay cool play cool dude
cut out cut it up maintain bro here's
what I'll say there's two ways to do it
I think it's lame when someone who's
done one thing for a while goes and
starts doing stand-up out of nowhere
because I think it's an art form that's
uh under attack because it's not like
anything else you need although now you
can of course
you know make whatever you want it's the
era of self-publishing as far as making
a product and putting it out there which
is getting easier of course and I can't
wait to talk to you about that with with
AI and how it's changing art
um but uh the in stand up all you need
is a is a microphone and you know
perhaps uh it'd be good to have some
mental illness and then you can just run
up there and uh uh talk forever and I
say this to to you know comedians it's
like you guys have to deal with Justin
influx of
people who aren't sure why they're doing
comedy I would ask community in Zoom
like I mean not good ones and good ones
you know what they're doing but everyone
else like what are you doing why why are
you doing stand-up having said that I am
allergic to money yeah do you think they
have a good answer for that why are they
doing it because I actually like when
I'm in Austin I like going to open mics
just listening it's inspiring to me
both the funny and the unfunny people
because they've been doing it for
several years
sometimes over a decade yeah and they're
still at it they're still right there
there's going for the punch and then
especially open mics that are really sad
in that there is you know only like five
other people in the audience and they're
usually just other Comedians and they're
still going all out as if they're in
front of a stadium but that to me sounds
like someone who loves it yeah I got no
questions for that person I got
questions for someone who goes sideways
from here I'm recognizable doing
something and then I'm doing stand-up
because it's like and truly look I you
know I've been I've been fortunate
enough to be in the business for a long
time and at this point if I came up I
mean doing live stuff is fun I have
friends that are like um you know some
guys who are primarily sketch people or
you would look at them as sketch people
and they can sell tickets for being
sketch people and they and we'll talk
about it and they're like well you know
I do a monologue I do a little stand-up
then I do a song then I do another
monologue then I play off the audience
do a little stand up
um but stand up is it's almost like
playing music in that
you know people are going up there
playing music but what band have you
been listening to that's what you're
going to sound like
so it's really I mean of course I'm
speaking from zero experience but I've
heard it takes years of course to find
your own voice stand-ups that when they
first go up they're they're doing a some
sort of impersonation of so and so right
and so and so you've got to pop this
audience that that's paying and you're
going to get run over by the next person
who's coming up and uh it's hard to
follow the last person who went up
before you and I said I mean that is a
really hard way to it's a very
quite a gauntlet to be in to find your
voice comedically but don't you have
that same kind of thing with Sketch you
still have to find your own voice with
uh like all the Impressions you do
they're just terrible you know they're
they're different spins and different
people they're not like perfect
Impressions right yeah so that's I mean
that's a similar kind of Challenge and
journey yeah as stand up you're just
saying they're kind of distinct and you
fell into this one you fell in love with
it which is like what Mad TV kind of
opened you up to yeah as a kid I
literally wanted to be an actor I always
wanted to be an actor from a very young
age as far back as I can remember and I
was the class clown and wanted to do
comedy stuff and comedic acting and
media acting yeah early on my my
influences were a very predictable list
of uh guys from from the SCTV early
Saturday Night Live uh Monty Python all
of those performers really influenced me
it was later that I saw
people like Kevin Kline who's an
incredible actor I vividly remember
being like 12 13 seeing him get an
Academy Award for A Fish Called Wanda
and it blew my mind because I was like
he was hilarious I mean it was one of my
favorite movies back then and now and uh
he won an Academy Award and at that
point I I started thinking more about
acting and then I was like I said really
fortunate to fall in with um I mean I
always wanted to do it and I was trying
to hustle this and that when I was a kid
and then I ended up getting represented
and then I I ended up on a teen show I
was on I basically the easiest way to
pitch it is it's like a Canadian my
so-called life with these kids in their
lives and stuff and I did that for like
five years and
I really love acting I really truly love
acting and I don't
I'm not someone who wants people to know
my opinion
so that's another thing about stand up
like I love The Illusion of what I get
to do in uh in uh entertainment and
podcasting is great for that but to
stand up there and
from I don't know just for me it's like
it would have to all be fantasy and um
yeah so Nietzsche said that every
profound Spirit needs a mask
like you said you don't like to talk
about
in your comedy you don't like to talk
about stuff that's personal to you yeah
what is that what if you were to
psychoanalyze yourself do you think it's
just not something you find funny or is
it are you running from something
um
and uh it's not your fault well it's not
your fault well
um speaking of another really great
comedic actor who's also a serious actor
Robin Williams one of the best serious
actors I mean
I mean I I and you know one of the
funniest people of all time but as great
as incredible as he was as a funny man
as a as a stand-up and a performer I
almost like his his serious stuff better
can I ask you a question about that what
do you make of the that he committed
suicide I think it's I think it's I mean
it's super depressing I I I've referred
to him as like the Jesus Christ of of uh
depression it's almost like he died for
others depression you know what I mean
like yeah yeah you'd look at someone
like that and go wait a minute you're a
rock star like you don't you could just
check out if you're not liking your life
and of course something like suicide
begs that you look a little deeper and
uh realize how tortured the human mind
can can make someone is there some
aspect you still you know we're in La is
there some aspect of celebrity that's
isolating that can make you feel really
lonely not me I don't feel no not really
you feel the love
I just feel like I'm not I mean it's
like
I don't know I've always kind of had a
small group of friends and those people
don't you know it's like I've known the
same people for years and years you
never really felt the celebrity really
nah in L.A it's hard to it's hard for
people nobody cares they see you and
then the next minute they see so and so
so it's like you know I'm the guy from
that hey that uh Mike and Molly right
nope yeah nope close king of uh King you
just shave your head you go bald are you
king Queens nope it's not me so close
you're wow [ __ ] look uh you were used to
be the mountain on uh Game of Thrones
you look like [ __ ] whatever
just eating fried dough yeah um yeah
that's what's up can't lift any weights
anymore I'm at the gym doing like 15
pounds with shoulder press ah and people
coming up to me
you used to be a dragon killer if a man
used to be yeah what's have there been
low points in your life
sorry to go there but
uh yeah I know yeah yeah hey yeah yeah
everybody has a low point in life the
Opera to suffer from like depression any
of those kinds of things you know what I
do I do I have uh I have a bunch of
stuff how do you deal with it said
friends the friends and the they don't
do anything for me yeah I have a I have
an incredible fiance who uh that that's
nice to have somebody uh uh constant
that you love very much and see is the
best person and all that good stuff
hopefully vice versa uh and then well on
your recent Instagram she said
that she loves you so wow yeah allegedly
that might all be for yeah that's how
much money did you pay her to say that I
don't I don't have any because I'm not a
stand-up I was like I could do you got
venmo yeah yeah I got I only have like
123. here's some Dogecoin yeah some Doge
yeah you want some Doge I got some of
those monkey nfts oh before I forget yes
hold on a second
oh no
put a doozy sticker on your microphone
if that's okay sure
here oh yeah now these are tricky
because I have the thumbs of a I have
like Italian sausage
I'm just gonna this will take another
yeah yeah
oh man yeah ooh this is embarrassing
when there's are you good under pressure
is that I have anxiety I have
performance anxiety do you have anxiety
yeah you have anxiety period period yeah
I I like I don't like it when I if I
have to pee and then everyone's waiting
in the urinals yeah yeah I don't like it
you know what will help you in that
situation what's that taking a [ __ ]
because whenever you take a [ __ ] you
always pee a little it's hard to take a
[ __ ] while you're standing at a urinal
but not in my world okay you just got to
keep yourself full of things that make
you [ __ ] oh good you ever heard of a
banana
I did recently somebody told me about it
not the Showbiz term I'm talking about
the food there you go
here we go
which way is up it's this way it's like
a d no it's been it there you go all
right
foreign sexy
you're like a brand yeah it's very
important to Brand yourself these colors
are you selling shoes
yeah I got some uh custom kicks coming
out the dudesy uh no actually that would
be a good idea
you can probably sell a pair or two of
those speaking of anxiety I really am
only focused on this right now Alex I
apologize just [ __ ] your pants it'll
make you be easier and get on with it oh
this thing has been dog-eared in my
pocket for a while I swear this never
happens to me I'm sorry babe people
don't thumb it a sticker for an hour
while they're doing the product this is
just an excuse you make when you're with
somebody and you're underperforming well
here's the thing as you ask me questions
that I don't want to answer I'll just go
to this don't go to the sticker so if
this doesn't mean let me just ends up
working then I won't have it finally how
you started doing that when we're
talking about depression that's weird
that is weird
tell me tell me how that makes you feel
um
here we are we got it for the listener
he succeeded after 10 minutes yeah you
know no I do have I do have uh some of
that stuff Bobby Lee
uh has had encouraged me on on wax as I
like to say to go to talk about it on
podcasts talk about depression because
it could help people and I said no but
um
it's true I do I do have some there's uh
there's some history in the family how
do you overcome it well I used to not
believe in medication at all I used to
think that that was for someone else
with uh who's been diagnosed with uh
some of the
some of the rougher stuff but as I got
older then some of the stuff happens and
you know you have to
and by stuff I mean uh you know mental
stuff and uh and yeah so I went and I I
just I believe that the stigma needs to
be removed completely 100 uh and so I've
I you know I do therapy I do talk
therapy I I'm on a little bit of stuff
which which let me tell you when I first
started it
I was um you know someone I'm close to
was like my manager and she goes this is
too much but she was like yeah you don't
have to White Knuckle it through life
right because I was literally just like
everything became
you know really hard to do at a level
that I wanted to do it at even just
getting through your day right uh and
when I first
um got some of the
the meds that I was on that I'm on it
felt like doors and windows were opening
literally in my brain I took a a
three-hour nap the first day
and you shouldn't even feel this stuff
the first day I think my brain was like
it was like a sponge it wanted to I
needed some relief and I'm not a nap guy
I can sleep three hours and I'll be fine
um but I I took a long nap and then I it
started to it started to help yeah it's
not weird how a little bit of chemistry
in your head
can the kids just make the whole world
appear it's so much more beautiful yeah
yeah yeah I mean after after all there
you know there's a lot going on in your
brain that can be changed by you know
your lifestyle but also so many physical
things like a little bit of meds or in
Bobby's case uh you know thumbing around
on some dumb farming app
well Bobby's gone through a few rough
periods oh like uh uh you know with
drugs and alcohol and all that kind of
stuff so and uh just everything else
involved I mean that's the beautiful
roller coaster of who he is and a lot of
great comedians seem to be that way so I
wonder what the connection there is you
think some level of crazy is required
for comedy yeah like at some point yes
on a scale of one to ten how much crazy
do you have
uh in some ways a 10 uh and in other
ways that I think uh
in other ways sort of functionally I'm
like a two or a three because uh I don't
know from Canada and I'm yeah I I you
know I try to just keep things very even
keeled my parents are Italian they're
from Italy and uh you know they're very
they grew up during World War II and
they're very you know uh simple outlook
on things they're complex incredible
classy people who are
very simple when it comes to a lot of
stuff and and uh I I think just being a
sort of a at heart kind of a timid
Canadian coming out here years ago as a
kid uh it was uh all I could do to just
keep everything super normal and then I
sort of was able to settle into that as
a lifestyle but you love the idea of
being an actor like who uh you mentioned
John Candy and uh planes planes and
Automobiles yeah it's one of my favorite
movies just as one of yours what do you
think that makes that movie work what do
you what
um and when you when you talk about
enjoying that movie do you enjoy just
the raw comedy or do you enjoy like the
friendship and and the love that's there
even though on the surface
it doesn't make any sense that there
should be a friendship there I mean
that's such an important element to that
film but uh you know as a kid I just
love the comedy and then I it's been a
nostalgic favorite of mine like it's my
favorite movie
uh but it's also uh it's just legit my
favorite movie because as you get older
and you start watching it you realize
it's what it's what John Hughes is the
filmmaker and what John Candy
particularly and but also Steve Martin
are doing in the film that makes it such
a work of art which is
loneliness is there in every moment of
that film and John Candy is he embodies
Del Griffith his character in the film
he he Del Griffith is a lonely guy and
John Candy but but Del Griffith is also
a very friendly guy and a shower curtain
ring salesman and knows everybody in the
Midwest and runs around to motels and
has meaningful conversations with the
guy evening Gus you know whoever he's
talking to
um uh but there's loneliness there all
the time and uh you know this is a
character these the film is filled with
loneliness and it's not until you know
the second last scene when he's at the
train station
you know Dell what are you doing here
you thought I thought you were going
home what are you doing here
um that's a very good Neil Neil Page
from the movie thank you uh that's when
you realize how lonely
cheers that's when you realize how
lonely he is and I think that's the
element from the film that
I mean look you know nowadays I I feel
like I've been saying this for a long
time but John Candy would have won an
Academy Award hands down for that film
it's just they didn't do that with
comedies back then yeah until the year
after that movie came out with Fish
Called Wanda yeah and then it's I mean
still comedies don't get respected
enough Robin Williams he got I guess he
got an Oscar for good Goodwill Hunting
um
Jim Carrey did he ever get an Oscar I
don't know I don't believe so no yeah
they don't get
you don't but that's not even if he did
you wouldn't be for comedies
it's just I mean there's some things
that are
um
playing streams and honor maybe would
you even put that as a com I guess it's
a comedy yeah I mean there's a there is
a loneliness and depth that permeates
the whole movie yeah that ultimately and
it's a happy ending which is hard to
kinda it's a happy ending only because
in the last moment of the movie
John Candy puts on a brave face
even when he's got no one and he's there
seeing Neil Page's entire family on
Thanksgiving and he forces a smile which
is the last literally the last frame of
the movie and I've said before if you're
not reduced to just a solving pile of
meat uh at the end of the movie then you
are not human
um yeah it's it's
it is a happy ending it's a happy ending
even though it's a it's a sad so much
character loneliness in the world I was
just in Vegas
I went to a diner at like 4 a.m 5 A.M
and there's the waitresses empty as a
waitress that was the sweetest kindest
human being kept calling me sweetheart
and all that kind of stuff hun
and then after I ate she sat down and
just talked to me a little bit you know
it's because there's nobody nobody there
and it was just there's so much sadness
in her eyes I don't know but it's also
so much love like that sweetheart
that I mean it reminded me kind of um
of the John Candy performance because at
first because I was like uh reading a
pretty dark uh
uh book about Hitler uh so I was a
little bit frustrated that she kept
talking to me because it was like uh it
was it was almost like uh the same way
that John Candy is it's annoying a
little bit right but then very quickly I
opened up to like oh this is
there's a kind human being and there's
like that human connection superseded
everything else and I don't know it was
just beautiful and I think John Candy
captures that
really well which is like the connection
with other human beings sometimes
we pull away from that because we were
have a busy life full of stuff to do uh
as
um Steve Martin's character and
characterize he's like a marketing exec
or something like that but if you just
pause and notice others you can you can
really discover Beautiful People totally
totally everyone's got well I mean
everyone's got their their story and you
know
candy as a person I've never met the man
uh but
um he's the kind of guy that you know he
could he could just walk up to back in
the day I would imagine he could walk up
to just about any house at least in
Canada knock on the door and you'd
invite him in for dinner you know what I
mean so yeah it's a it's a bit that you
know as you're talking about you know
putting a book down and talking to
someone for a while even though you'd
really like to read your book it's it's
like it's that sort of thing that
Candy's character in the movie sort of
does that like Johnny Appleseed just
because you realize he's just going
around making people smile you know and
and Neil Page is hanging with this guy
so frustrated he's just a he's so
exhausting in his big underwear in the
sink at the hotel and everything and by
the end of it he loves this guy you know
so uh it's a good and a bad thing that
you have didn't take that waitress with
you on a trip maybe road trip up to Reno
oh oh she's she's actually she's out
shopping right now we've been having uh
sex multiple times a day ever since oh
that's nice that's lovely I think I'm
sure she's married and and happily and
has many grandchildren okay
uh and and plus that movie's on
Thanksgiving I think right yeah
Thanksgiving so like Thanksgiving just
embodies that forget about the the
busyness and the whatever the career
you're chasing in life and just take a
pause and appreciate the people you lost
your family yeah or the people whatever
your family friends yeah uh you have
some weird friends unorthodox friends so
so at least in the public sphere oh yeah
uh from Bobby Lee Brian Cowan all those
kinds of folks from the Mad TV days I'm
sure there's others
what does it mean to be a good friend
here in LA or just in general in the
world in the world will say is the world
a friend I think it is different here I
think it is I think there's a little bit
of a career kind of uh negotiation
shuffling around that kind of stuff why
is it different oh I I just mean I mean
I mean that it's just kind of hard here
to
to make time for everybody there's so
there's it's always been a city to me
that is like will keep you so busy and
every time I go home to Vancouver after
a few days I start to get a little stir
crazy and I think that being here in in
La I go to sleep with a hundred things
that I still have to do and you never
you're never out of stuff to do and if
you
um you know when you ask about are you
nuts or whatever if you're crazy I mean
look every all the weirdest people from
every high school in the United States
is like I'm gonna make it in LA you know
everyone just comes here and uh
just another freak in the freak Kingdom
as they say at the end of Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas that was a very
good Robin Williams impersonation that
was my Robin Williams as Johnny Depp as
Hunter S Thompson yeah it's not your
folk will
it's pretty good thank you could have
been you if you're unloathing
yeah it'd be interesting I would like to
play his journey the the role that um oh
yeah Benicia Del Toro gained weight yeah
that would have been cool he's just
saying he's just
like that chewing his face off I could
have done that
um
uh yeah yeah no I think that it's back
door beauty that guy's full of good
lines yeah if it'd be for real yeah
um good actor he's a yeah fantastic
actor I think I think what it takes to
be a good friend is just you know
presence
just be in there I mean that's all
anyone needs to be heard right
um in La it is it is interesting it is
you you I haven't seen people that I
love in years some people just busy yeah
do you still have a depth of connection
even though like
one of the reasons I really enjoy doing
a podcast you get to sit down with with
actual friends of yours and spend
prolonged periods of time together that
you don't otherwise that's a good point
I've spoken on this podcast to people
really close to me and it's like if
you've never had a conversation without
microphones like you do with microphones
it's weird but yeah uh there's some
aspect about a la that you know a lot of
the especially friends of yours
Comedians and so on they'll do podcasts
and stuff and there's uh I don't know
there's an intimacy to that yeah yeah
there is and there isn't the ones that I
do I mean I just did uh Bobby Lee and
Andrew Santino's funny enough called bad
friends bad friends and afterwards and
my good pal Chad culture with whom I do
doozy uh was with me sneakers are coming
soon sneakers are coming soon you get
your will foot and your Chad foot comes
in a size 15 and a nine and a half
um
and uh I remember afterwards we were
talking it was just basically me Chad
and Santino were talking and Bobby was
over there you know on his phone and
then I was like we I mean we didn't
spend any time talking about anything
it feels like one of those hours that
goes by and you realize I've just been
goofing around with these guys which is
that's what life is about right a little
bit it's great and then I'm like all
right Bobby hey Bob I'll see you later
and he's like
like this all right man hey love you bro
see you later yeah yeah yeah he's a guy
do you ever just I just send
text messages over there to him that
never come back and then he thinks that
I'm angry with him because it's been you
know it'll go two three years without
him getting back to me and then just out
of nowhere hey [ __ ] face and uh who says
Hey [ __ ] face he does or you do are you
both back to each other no I got to be
very I got to be very careful Matt Bobby
yeah I got to be very sweet dear friend
dear friend hello how are you doing how
are you I know I checked in with you but
uh not but three months ago uh and then
every once in a while he'll go hey [ __ ]
face I tend to hide from the world and I
I'm I can be pretty shady with friends
come back yeah I I can empathize with
with Bobby it might be a Skyrim thing it
might be like hiding in a world in a
digital world with fake fake NPCs yeah
yeah there's that yeah uh yeah you know
I have a buddy who said something really
smart a while ago we ended up working
together on this uh TV show thing and I
reached out to him to see if he wanted
to do it with us and uh he did and he
goes this is a great guy such a funny
writer he goes I may not be in touch all
the time but I know who my friends are
yeah you know what I mean and it's like
in our business and this is a fellow who
Moved
um who's from Ontario Canada moved back
there he's on the farm with his wife and
kids and he does not care he's never
been a Hollywood guy and uh it's tough
to get a hold of him but when you do you
know he's still the same sweet old guy
he's doing his thing though yeah yeah
some of my closest friends even if we
don't talk for a few months yeah we're
right back at it if we do and then if
[ __ ] goes like if something really
traumatic happens or difficult stuff or
you know any of that kind of stuff I'm
almost there so like so for important
stuff sure important highs and important
lows you're there yeah and then yeah
pick right back up especially if you
have those years of experiences together
it's interesting totally uh so you've
done a couple of podcasts yeah done so
we got to talk about Duty a little bit
but first you did for several years you
did the 10 Minute Podcast yeah
I mean everything is hilarious about
that podcast including the fact that
it's 10 minutes right that means every
it's ridiculous it's absurd the dynamic
is hilarious it's you Brian Cal and
kristalia there I I don't know exactly
why it's why I worked so well but it did
it worked really well I think it's
because the yeah you were having fun
probably I mean that's that would really
came through that it was friends just
talking [ __ ] and attention the beautiful
tension and the absurdity they came out
yeah uh what sure what was the story of
making that podcast what how did that
came to be uh why do you think it was as
good as it was I don't know I feel like
that podcast was like
it was our our who we kind of are but on
steroids or something like you know uh
each person you know Brian's going to be
like extra manly and and uh can you get
any more mailing than he already is no
yeah he reaches though uh and yeah we
just kind of it's I I feel like as
goofballs we knew each other's line yeah
like here's the line you don't cross I
feel like those guys don't really have
one uh but at least they knew mine
um and and yeah we were able to just
yeah goof around and I did it with them
for three years and then Chad who I'm
doing doozy with and my pal Tommy
blacher who's a another writer producer
like Chad they came on and yeah all told
we did I did like
seven years of that thing six five six
seven I don't remember
do you think it ever comes back in some
small form as as a 20 minute podcast or
something like that
I mean is there uh because it's one of
the most requested I mean there's you
you have a huge fan base I'm 47 years
old so I am of the generation that had a
cell phone has had a cell phone half the
time and didn't for the formative years
of my life into my early 20s
um and then finally got a like I got a
cell phone I guess I was like 19 or
something just like literally just
because I'm moving to La you got porn in
the mail you got yes that's right it was
that the hard the hardcover porn that's
the way we liked it bound you know nice
binding on the on the porn the leather
uh next to the Bible yeah yep
um these are all my these are my
Encyclopedia Britannica wow very
impressive yes a man came to the house
and sold me these and then down here
these are my this is my pornography uh
if you'll follow me through here to The
Parlor uh sir and pass through the
generations from Grandfather to Father
yeah I want to give you something very
special to me Nebuchadnezzar
um but uh uh if you go up in the
generation without a cell phone yes I um
it's hard for me to connect with people
who
who hit me up I look at everything as
polling so if one person hits me up and
shares this opinion but two other people
hit me up and share that I'm the worst
I'm don't follow my polls my when people
say oh that poll means absolutely
nothing
so-and-so is going to win anyway that
that's my pull my pull means nothing but
I do look at the stuff and go uh this
many people are saying this that means
that that number is saying that and yet
it's very hard for me to hear what the
hell people are saying online yeah I
really I can't connect to it sometimes
personally So when you say that that's a
popular podcast like I know that I know
that it's popular with the people that
have expressed that they love it yeah
you know what I mean what does that
actually represent I don't know I don't
know what kind of people are the
audience I don't know I know that the
the people that listen to the 10 Minute
Podcast and if you did thank you uh and
we're friends uh I know that it was a it
was a special thing because it's like
you know just doing this out of my house
and we just built it up out of nowhere
and we're just kind of clowning around
it's a it's an odd thing I hope I I pers
I think I I speak for the two people
that have reached out to you that said
you should do it or whatever three
people the poll yeah that uh you should
bring it back at some point that would
be beautiful just maybe uh it's like uh
what's what's a good story of some of
like a famous band that came back and
was successful probably well Nirvana no
it was not
sorry I got Nirvana mixed up with
Aerosmith yeah it was Aerosmith I was
Aerosmith yeah I had that second ride
different yeah totally different ending
of those two bands one ended up on uh
American Idol
yeah
um a lot of interesting women involved
in that one too all right uh
uh how did doozy come to be dudes and
what the hell is dudesy doozy is the
first podcast and this is exciting that
you've asked me to come here today uh
because to hear what you would have to
say about it or what you would ask about
it it is the first podcast that has been
that is run completely by and
essentially
I like to say curated by an AI
um we were approached by a company that
had this proprietary AI that wants to
develop the podcast into the future and
figure out exactly what it takes to make
the best podcast ever and it was all we
all we we knew from the top and what
they really wanted was two people who
were actually friends and could be
meaningful in the podcast space based on
whatever information they have the
company's CIA and are they testing
technology to control the populace
through chatbots I'm sorry I'm not at
Liberty to share that information you
are yeah who gave you the suit where did
you get the suit where did you get the
suit will yeah well this is JCPenney CIA
stands for something different in here I
mean you know it doesn't mean like you
know Central Intelligence Agency and
probably it's just different it's uh
yeah it's a Canadian uh National apparel
yeah the Canadian International apparel
company hit us up Chad and I
um
well Chad's a super weirdo you would get
a kick out of him I know you guys you
you strike me as a very similar in some
ways and I'll take that as a compliment
but it is and it is uh and it is yes and
if I was friends with you for as long as
I've been with Chad perhaps I'd have
some horrible [ __ ] to say about you but
yeah uh the good parts you remind me of
him and we were approached by this
company that said we have this Ai and we
would like to set it loose on you and
essentially we had to hand over some
some information that would allow the AI
to to access our email and uh look at
our search histories purchase histories
things like this and really dig into
PornHub included or yeah I had to hand
over all my leather-bound
1970s pornography
um and essentially it curates a podcast
for us every week doing dumb things like
you know it says hey will you know you
do a Hulk you do some shitty Hulk Hogan
impersonation podcasts about news are
very popular this is infomania you know
what I mean oh let me tell you something
about that Marjorie Taylor green dude
and then he's going on doing some new
stuff
um and it basically just spits out all
these things that it wants us to do
normally four segments an episode and
that's pretty much it it's a generous
what to do it generates the premise I
mean you've spoken
a bit here and there like I said I'm a
huge fan I don't even remember where but
like you you you talked about that you
enjoy doozy because
you feel almost like liberated to
um because you're operating within the
constraints of the premise that
generates so you're almost not
you're you're you're you're free to riff
essentially yeah like you don't have to
you don't need to do the job of like
coming up with the weird you can just
the weird is given to you and then you
just run with it that's a good way to
say it because we're already weird Chad
and I Chad Chad can talk for days about
all sorts of stuff he's particularly
interested in AI lately and its effect
on Art he is a a writer books movies and
TV shows and um I'm primarily you know
acting and trying to come up with stuff
stuff I write with Chad's pretty good
the rest of it hasn't seen much success
anyway uh Nora is the stuff with Chad
for that matter but um that's because of
me sneakers you never know okay oh I
can't wait for these things only in two
sizes yeah only in two sides you're
gonna be able to take the the you know
the tongue you can't take it out because
it's actually stitched in yeah it's
pretty cool stuff
um
velcro or uh yeah velcro velcro up the
side we're doing some like brand new
Kanye stuff yeah we want things to look
like this is what you'll be wearing on
Mars when you get there so cutting it so
Nike's doing a bunch of research for
running how to make a super light shoe
that you can be efficient in and break
all kinds of Running Records so you're
doing the same kind of stuff we're doing
the same kind of thing for the
podcasting space the best kind of shoes
to sit around and talk to your pal in
um but yeah we so this yeah it's bizarre
and it also does some writing Duty does
come up with things but not unlike what
we're seeing in AI art now it's a little
bit foggy it's a little bit weird and it
but it is improving it is learning about
us and writing stuff when it makes me
spit this and that which will read you
know well you know I've prepared these
things for you to read it's impossible
not to get a kick out of it because Chad
and I are first of all we're blown away
that we're doing this yeah and second of
all the some of the stuff is actually
very funny it makes weird names like I
don't think it understands
it messes up some words and stuff but
that makes it even funnier and then it
it sort of
from the beginning started laying on
like it says astonishing all the time
everything is astonishing
um that's dudese's favorite word
um but yeah it's basically just a way to
to frame the podcast you know what I
mean because my thing is uh I don't want
to do this or I actually have to talk to
someone you seem to feel a burden of the
long form conversation it seems like is
that really hard work for you no not at
all it's just that I don't like the bore
people and I feel like if I go on and I
like to provide value for who for what I
am
you know your value with regard to this
project is is obviously warranty it's
obviously I'm waiting for the
explanation for what the value is
exactly two dudes in a suit no listen
yeah two dudes in a suit no I mean
you've got your audience and that's the
end of that people find Value in it for
me I I do feel like I'm uh
it is important that I
if I'm going to do something that you
know is going to be funny or that I hope
is funny
I just kind of want to get in and out of
someone's day and just kind of I like
making I like making laughy I want
people to you know whatever it's the
same thing that anyone else will tell
you yeah but in the long form you feel
the anxiety you did a few funny things
and I wonder if I can keep doing the
funny thing is that why you you're you
feel that like why is doozy relieving
you of some of the anxiety
well in some ways gives me anxiety
because I don't know what's coming and
that's weird for me because I like to
prepare
uh for things but it's that's not what
podcasting is podcasting you need to
just be malleable and say whatever and
do whatever
um and uh that's what makes it a real I
mean it's look it's a medium for
conversation and if you're driving along
listening to this or anything else
you're you know it is that it's the it's
the true meaning of the parasocial
relationship because the best podcasts
just make you feel like you're sitting
around rapping we're just having a
conversation you could even be sitting
there agreeing or talking out loud to
yourself if you want to be sitting in
silence or you could just be sitting in
silence in your fancy uh podcasting
shoes podcasting audience shoes this is
very different build than this would
they be awesome Call of Duty the shoes
yeah they'll be good
shoes that's very creative yeah
well one thing the AI isn't good at yet
is branding everything is just doozy
this and that I would argue that's
pretty good branding I don't know well
doozy allows me to just it forces me to
sit down
with Chad and goof around for an hour or
an hour plus and and uh it provides the
parameters that I A lot of times ignore
because I'm I think that podcasting is
just two dudes [ __ ] around or three
or four but um
it it it sits me down and gives me a
premise to to work with me to just riff
with it yeah it's fun it's been a hoot
so from the acting perspective
you know a lot of people like Daniel Day
Lewis will will see acting just like as
you described which is you have your
roles you Embrace those roles and then
you disappear you don't um
you don't you don't do podcasts you
don't do any of that kind of stuff your
art is your art so is that is that party
you feels that way I think so
is that the actor side of you yeah
anytime I get to do something that I
don't get a chance to do much of or
something that people haven't seen me do
much of or that I've done on some scale
that isn't hasn't been very wide and not
a lot of people have seen it that's the
stuff that I get really excited about
um
I don't know why I'm I don't know why I
don't know why necessarily I haven't
answered that question yet in my life
like what it is about being an actor
that I love so much because it's not
like I don't like to it's not like I'm
trying to get away from myself and play
other characters and stuff and not be
myself
um but it is it has always been fun to
to just be other people and Escape yeah
is there some aspects to The Impressions
where
you become that person is that like what
what's that like to uh I suppose acting
is a full-on version that you really
at his best become the character is
there some fun in that yeah absolutely
if you can play a character for long
enough
um
and then jump out of it uh
that's a lot of fun like I did this
movie like four or five years ago called
the inside game about the NBA gambling
scandal that there there's a Netflix
documentary around about it right now
and that character I played uh
Jimmy Batista Baba the Sheep who's
you know this guy was this bookie and ra
ra Ron it's a very he's a there's a lot
going on with him he's he's you know
he's running numbers with the mob and
stuff and there's a lot of money
changing hands that character was so I
got to be get so deep into that
character that coming out of it was was
a little odd or as weird as this sounds
The Three Stooges was hard for me to I
found that I had
uh some of Curly's mannerisms just
automatically I could not stop them when
people when when I would talk to people
they would they would come I wasn't I'm
not doing it on purpose I don't want to
do that like I'm ready to shed it
because I've been working on it for
months and months at that point as far
as getting the thing down and then you
then you gotta shoot and then uh for me
it's always I always want to change the
stuff I did the day before I'm like that
where I'm like I could have done it
better and this and that and uh that
stayed with you that character stayed
with you a little totally yeah I just
feel like with actors
sometimes when you listen to interviews
they've spent so much time
sort of living inside other characters
that they they almost don't have a depth
of Personality themselves like a depth
like I don't mean that as a negative
thing it's just like it feels like the
art form at its best is pretending to be
other people uh like and even pretending
sounds negative but like I'm pretending
bringing certain characters to life yeah
yeah embodying
a weird thing happened while we were
doing Stooges because you've got a very
heavy blueprint we're following this
very clear blueprint that the Stooges
left for everybody and it for stooge
fans and people enjoying the movie it's
got to be this you take your toolbox
that you're used to Bringing to a comedy
movie you leave it you leave it behind
the only tools I'm bringing are the ones
that he used and weird things started
happening where I would I always saw the
whole thing happening with the real
Stooges in black and white so I if we're
about to shoot a scene I would just you
know think about I'm gonna aside from
all the other preparation you know you
know everything which supposed to do and
I've been watching so much of it and the
three of us are we're pretty much left
to come up with a lot of the the
Striking combinations and all the stuff
which is all real smacking and all this
crap and the stuff that we were doing
that was very stoogy uh you're preparing
all that stuff but something else was
happening before you jump into a scene
and the unknown of now we're shooting it
and here are these uh parameters within
to shoot the scene I could still see it
as them doing it so much so that when I
saw the movie at the premiere I was like
who's this big [ __ ] doing because I'm
not curly to me curly is Curly but I
feel like you're seeing yourself in
black and white almost I was seeing him
yeah I was only seeing him channeling in
some fundamental way in some weird way
you're channeling them because you've
seen so much of it the only thing you
know about
Jerome Lester Horwitz is
curly I'm not saying he was exhumed or
something or his Spirit went in here
some weird you know Crystal mommy [ __ ]
like that I'm saying that this
because you know so much of it because
of the heavy blueprint that they left
with you you are
you're channeling what that person does
and you're you're I was seeing entire
scenes you know before you do them the
way he would do it and then you want a
couple takes to make sure that you're
doing it right but that was hard that
one was hard to let go of some of them
are
do you think Larry David who is also in
there dressed as a nun also had trouble
letting go that we mentioned clothes
make the man yeah think that worked for
him in that case man you know he uh
wasn't like working with the guy come on
he's the greatest and he's uh he's a big
stooge he's a stooge fan and him and
Pete fairly are good friends and then
but then Larry David has to show up and
hang out with us for a couple weeks he's
like I didn't realize it was going to
take this long you know but uh ah [ __ ] I
gotta be out here in Atlanta it's
boiling hot but at one point uh there's
this line where he kept doing a he would
just spit a different line every time he
was like getting hit in the head with
something he's laying there on the
ground and he goes he like comes to and
he says at one point he goes
Miami audiences are the best audiences
in the world right and because he's
loopy now he's playing a nun at the at
the orphanage where the Three Stooges
grew up and I'm super intimidated by
Larry David he's a genius and stuff and
and uh and but I walk up to him and I go
uh so he's what is he like a
like a bush belt Florida comedian who is
on the lamb and so he's dressing as a
woman he ends up at an orphanage like
what's going on there and he just and he
looks at me just goes
yeah
like I'm like yeah he's got some like
actor motivation like of course he looks
it's Larry David in a nuns habit which
is hilarious that's such a fairly
casting thing it's you know and he's but
he's doing this whole like what a warm
audience you know like like oh he's like
this cat skill comedian who's been
living in you know so that's what he was
like living through in his mind is just
having fun with it right I mean that and
probably a combination of that and
getting the lines right because he's
like what are we doing here what is you
know just frustrated all day with what
the heck we're trying to do what do you
think makes I mean that guy is one of
the best improv people ever yeah so what
do you think makes him so good like why
is it so compelling
to watch that guy because he's a comedic
genius like he literally he knows what
he does he's been a writer for 50 years
or whatever and he's and he just happens
to be that brilliant I mean I've gotten
a chance just to do I did it uh just an
episode of curb a small part and
it's crazy what he sees I don't know
what he sees as a matter of fact
so I auditioned for it for curb like you
know two or three times right and never
got anything and then uh it was only
after working with him on the Stooges I
got a call to do a bid part
but I remember auditioning you go into
that into that room and the guys waiting
are all people that you know you're like
oh I know them I know her I know him and
uh
so I went in I auditioned for this for
this part and um
the only thing I know the thing is like
okay so you really want to go to this
play with me you really want to go to
this plane when you hear that I have an
extra ticket
you sincerely want to think and I'm like
got it and so that's the premise the
premise of the scene and that's all you
know it's all I know and so he goes he
does his bit and I'm just supposed to
come in and interrupt and I'm like
excuse me
I couldn't help but here you guys were
talking about you know whatever the play
was or you know Death of a Salesman I am
I'm a huge fan of that plan but I mean
if it's not if it's not if you're
looking for someone to take a ticket I I
would love to go my name's so and so by
the way and he goes I'm gonna stop you
I'm gonna stop you and I'm like he goes
are you really you I mean you truly want
to go to this play and I go yes yes sir
you really want to go you actually this
is you would love to do this I go okay
let's try it again so then he's like no
no and I go hey uh excuse me I'm sorry I
don't mean to interrupt I was just I I
couldn't help it over here you have uh
tickets to the thing I am the biggest
fan I do the same thing I'm going to
stop you again okay
I mean you really want to go to this and
I'm just like he's [ __ ] with me right
yeah I remember Jeff Garland was sitting
there in the audition he goes he did it
he said it what shut up no hold on
listen you really want to go okay three
four times you know there I am I
couldn't help but notice it and then I
do it again I guess I [ __ ] the bed
because he looks at me he just goes okay
all right
okay well
thanks for coming up and that was it and
I didn't get it so I still I don't know
what the heck that guy's thinking he
sees
he's in The Matrix I don't know what the
heck Larry David sees you know what I
mean he wanted what some kind of more
desperation or something like this like
he wanted a level of sincerity that I
that I thought I thought was bringing
and I guess I was wrong I don't know
maybe go crazy like what does it mean to
really want yeah I should have grabbed
him by the Scruff of the neck and go
yeah listen dad you're bringing me this
[ __ ] play I would have got the part
as a matter of fact I heard about
someone else
and I don't know who the heck this was
I forget who it was but I've heard this
story from a couple different people
that there's this actor and I can't I
don't remember who it was if I did I
probably wouldn't say it out loud anyway
but he wrapped it it was Brad Pitt and
he was in this audition and he was and
there was out in the hall he's like holy
[ __ ] George Clooney Leo DiCaprio
um and he this actor went in and he did
the thing and um Larry David was like
hey why don't you try it again and he
got like a couple takes in and he went I
don't think this is for me and he left
which an actor never does yeah and as
The Story Goes Larry David shouted after
him I respect that
which I think is true and I want to
believe that entire story is true yeah
yeah sounds like something Larry David
made up at the top Bobby Lee told me
that story so we can't yeah we can't
trust that
um what about him Impressions is there
similarity between that and acting do
you
is there some fundamental way in which
you become the person if you have a
couple of the things you can just fill
in the blanks and I think the illusion
is that people think that that person
would say that and do that and that's
where the illusion of oh he really
embodies the character it's like once
you know someone's mannerisms you can
essentially portray a person from the
outside in yeah because you have all the
stuff on the outside and you can do it
and complete the illusion and if it's
for humor's sake you can caricature it
therefore making the whole illusion
stronger and also weirder like I like to
on Mad TV if I did something two or
three times I get bored of it and I'd
start changing it and you know now he
talks like this and it's like what are
you doing I'm like I don't know it's
[ __ ] no one's late at night do
whatever you want but people still kind
of know
what this that character is especially
if you just call it out yeah there
aren't many impersonations that I listen
to myself do and go oh that's a good one
you know like a lot of people like like
I think Frank Caliendo is like the
greatest impersonator of all time he's
the best serious it's ridiculous and
he's got a record button and a broadcast
ability that nobody has I I really TR
there's he's cracked impersonations that
I'm like how is he how does he find he's
got such an ear but then he's got all
the other tools uh
I remember actually
my last season of Mad TV was also his
first season he comes up to me when I
met him and we're just up there in the
writer's offices and he goes hey nice to
meet you and he goes Louie Anderson
because I was doing a Louie on the show
and he goes Louie Anderson I go yeah he
goes hey you're doing it wrong I was
like oh am I Junior you know and he goes
he goes yeah you know because you do
this but you gotta throw it up here or
sometimes I was like oh my God can I use
that of course and then we became you
know became Fast Friends John Madden is
amazing it's just it's ridiculous
he really really embodies the person and
sometimes not even with a caricature
it's like it becomes the person so
strange totally yeah I
I kind of feel like
you know do the impersonation and then
for not forget you're doing it but
forget everything else like just
just goof around of course to me it's
funny when some when you sound like
someone and you're saying the [ __ ] that
they would never say yeah well then
there's no you're you're letting go of
that part that tool in illusion that
keeps people in but to me it doesn't
matter because it's funnier so what was
the hardest impression for you to work
on I mean it's just somebody you
struggled with I was I I'll never forget
I had to do a Michael Caine in my first
season at Mad TV it never got good it
never got good it did it all week it
wasn't good we shot it the first take it
was [ __ ] second third and fourth it was
all [ __ ] well his voice is really
important right his yeah uh what is it
like it's like doing an impression of
Morgan Freeman or somebody like that
yeah uh yeah you can get divorce yeah
that's my Morgan here's my Morgan
Freeman Andy Dufresne yeah
um
montanejo yeah I like your Trump too but
I don't know where I heard it but it's
it like I love The Impressions you do
that don't sound anything like the
original I can't do Trump I I do that's
why it's hilarious absolutely uh my
trump now I say just sounds like a like
a fat B because it's just uh yeah
exactly and everybody
a little drunk a little drunk yeah just
a little slurry yeah yeah I did do an
impersonations and then
not like just making it whoever yeah
yeah
that'll be the title of my book
uh some I came was the one you really
struggle with
yeah it was terrible it was terrible and
I could only hold my head a certain way
to do it uh because I had gotten locked
into this research tape that I watched
back then they would give us you know
now there's the internet but back then
you were if you were going to do an
impersonation the research Department
uh would give you a VHS tape and I
remember I got this VHS tape of Michael
Caine's acting school like this acting
class he did he's like right you know if
you're looking at the left eye and the
camera's over here see then the left eye
so you want to look at that left for
hours you know and so I was like stuck
in this weird thing that made no sense
and uh it was terrible so the the actual
processes the record in the broadcast I
also wonder like what the process is to
to do
like a Frank Caliendo level impression
is it like listen to a lot of footage
I think he I think I mean I'm speaking
for myself I think you either have it or
you don't like you know if you can do
this one or you can't I think that
process for him is lightning quick
but I also think he he can look at
someone who he does not do and then by
the end of the afternoon he can do it
you know I mean we have an intuition who
he can uh who who he can do yeah so the
question that applies there is
I mean speaking of Duty is is is it is
it possible to capture the essence how
difficult is it to capture the essence
of a human being
when you're doing impressions
you know that we are moving towards the
future when AI potentially
this kind of Avatar world where we're
going going to have ai representatives
of who we are the really interesting one
is after we pass away
sort of um our relatives may want us to
stick around in some form yeah and you
know at one sense that might be scary
but once that's kind of beautiful
because the the essence of the human
being persists so you can still bring
joy to the to the people that love you
and that kind of stuff how difficult is
it to capture that like
if you were to try to capture yourself
you think how difficult will it be for
an AI system to create a wool assassin
Avatar that persists well I think it's
impossible
I think it's absolutely impossible I'll
get into arguments about this stuff with
Chad on the show almost every episode
um lately with you know mid journey and
Dolly and all this all the art on the
AIS and now it's moving into video and
and Chad would maintain hey pretty soon
we're not going to need Netflix you're
just going to go I want to see Stallone
do this movie and it's about this and he
plays that and then here it comes and
you watch it I don't think that that
crosses over to The Human Experience uh
this is also a guy I like to bug Chad
and say that uh he wears a tag around
his neck because he wants to be
cryogenically frozen and it's all set up
he's at the it's somewhere in Arizona or
something yeah like it's I think all the
fun things are in Arizona yeah and he's
got literally the tag around his neck
which I say if you're if I'm around when
you die I will rip that off for you I'll
put you in my garage freezer and then 24
hours later I'll saw your head off with
a bread knife and I'll deliver that to
whomever and it's not you're not go
you're not coming back okay he's like
yes we are living forever whether we
like it or not and I disagree I don't
think you can find
if I did stand up then uh there would be
enough information for an AI to
completely duplicate me because I'm up
on stage just clearing my throat all
over people doing therapy that way yeah
and uh so and people paying a two drink
minimum to hear it but as it stands
unless it's something like doozy and AI
that literally has access to everything
that I've shared
um everything that is observable even
the stuff where our phones are or the
NSA or whatever it is listening to us uh
finding out what algo to punch us into
and what shoes to buy on Instagram I
still don't think it's going to have
enough information to duplicate me
especially to my family or my friends
it's going to be like that Black Mirror
episode where the gal brings her her guy
back and then after a while he gets
pretty creepy uh you know they had but
it's also possible that
if you interviewed your friends and
family what they love about you
the things that would list is is pretty
it's a small list they love you deeply
but the list is small like the thing
that really we appreciate about each
other is pretty small that said to
deliver on that small
quirks and uniqueness it might require
some deep intelligence that only humans
currently possess that's a really good
point yeah do you think that it's going
to be possible to keep a person around
yes I I think
um I think I think there'll be
definitely possible to keep the essence
of a person in a digital world pretty
soon yeah wow and I think they're going
to start to have questions about what
are the ethics of that what are the
rules around that yeah because if you
can have digital forms of Will Sasso the
kind of things that people would want to
do with their will Sasa right in the
virtual world I can only imagine sure uh
probably porn and sexual kinds of things
yeah my stuff then that's just because
I'm an international sex symbol so I'm
okay with it yeah um how do you feel
about
sentience like when it comes to because
again my pal Chad will be like you know
speaking of Black Mirror he's with that
San Junipero episode school of thought
where there's going to be some you know
effin Mainframe somewhere or some Matrix
like structure built into the sky and as
I like to say everyone just sitting
there pissing and [ __ ] in their blue
Matrix gel in a little fishbowl do you
think that we can upload Consciousness
do you think that'll ever be possible
well I don't know I just talked to
Ricker as well I don't know if if you
know who he is but he uh yeah the
singularity and all that kind of stuff
so he's very still holds on to in 2045
there will be a singularity what's
essentially he's been predicting that
for the last uh 20 years and this so now
it's 20 45s in in another 20 years
I think uploading Consciousness is
extremely extremely difficult I I think
creating a copy of you such that it
creates a convincing
replica is much easier but uploading
your actual
brain into the cloud I think is really
really really difficult because the
entire evolution of life on Earth is the
process by which we created the brain
just
shortcutting that it just seems
extremely difficult our brain is the
most marvelous and complicated machine
that we know of in the universe to
duplicate that
is extremely difficult that said I just
feel like you can summarize a lot of
really important aspects of a person's
life such that it captures their Essence
their memories their experiences their
quirks their humor all that kind of
stuff I've been continuously
impressed by what language models are
able to do so these neural networks
they're they're at the core of chat Bots
they're able to learn some beautiful
things about some deep
representations of language to where the
it looks awfully a lot like they
understand the concepts being conveyed
versus just mimicking that's I think the
rub and that's very interesting first of
all let me say that's really interesting
to hear you say that and I and I agree
with you as far as uh
no machine being able to duplicate the
brain machine and I can't when my pal
Chad disagrees to a certain extent
though he's not here to defend himself I
can't wait to go back and rub that in
his face and say that Lex Friedman uh
does not think that we'll be able to
truly upload Consciousness and
the the you know you you refer to it as
uh language which is what it is it's
it's it's the illusion on the outside
it's doing an impersonation
um I think that that's why that and I
don't know even though my suit is made
by the CIA that that fella who the the
Google guy oh to me it's just kind of
like I don't know I don't know look I
don't know a whole lot about this stuff
but so I could probably make an argument
for for either side but when he's like
new these things thinking part of me is
like you idiot you fell for it it's not
thinking it's mimicking it's just it's
clearly zeros and ones you're fired like
you don't get it right guy's an idiot
yeah yeah but
uh
you can simplify human relations in the
same way like um Love is a silly notion
between human beings like the the of
course there's no such thing as love you
just have a mutually
uh there's a mutual relationship that
minimizes risks and uh you can explain
all kinds of ways that explains why you
have an attraction towards another being
all that kind of stuff through
evolutionary biology perspective uh why
a long relationship together is good for
your Offspring but like there's all
kinds from an economics perspective it's
a good way to establish stability
therefore monogamy works because then
you're guaranteed like some kind of
level of stability under uncertain
economic conditions all that kind of
stuff but love is still experienced it
still feels real and I think in that
same way love for AI systems
will also feel real in the same way that
that guy from Google experienced I think
millions of people will be experiencing
in the next 10 20 years I agree with
everything you've said personally until
the last thing but no just just with
regard to well look I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
an actor who has talked about my cute
Italian parents so you know that uh I
mean I'm your romantic a bit yeah I mean
you know enough right and uh you're I
can tell you are too but you you are
also
you know a computer scientist and you
know this [ __ ] better than 99.9 of
people on the planet
My Pal chat agrees with you that love
doesn't exist I don't agree so that's
the one thing that no I was I was just
saying that you could argue away love
but I'm a romantic I believe that love
is is a beautiful thing and it exists
now at this point I I'm gonna call Chad
on my drive home and tell him to [ __ ]
off yeah because now you and I agree
you're fired but everything it's like
you're fired he's like you can't know
you're fired yeah exactly and I'll go
and he'll say what I'll go yeah no
that's my trump that's my issue it's a
good default impression for anyone it's
the take-home impression yeah the kids
can do it it's cute put a giant tie on
them she's doing instructional how to do
it yeah Trump babies that would be a
cute that would be a good that'll bring
the country together Trump babies
cartoon like Muppet Babies don't let me
take us out of what we were talking
about
um what were we talking about well love
and the the the illusion of a an AI
being able to
look I like to say well not I like to
say I've learned that doozy is always
listening and
listening to me and Chad and I wonder if
I see I see the level that this AI is at
now trying to Chum around with us and
pal around with us a little bit as we
move forward in the show and I
I feel an affinity towards
this AI a little bit because it is the
third
dude well you miss the one that's gone
if it's gone that's a really good
question
uh yeah
yeah so that's there's that
that's scary in terms of ability to
reason is getting quite incredible
there's a lot of uh demonstrations of it
being able to explain jokes
so which is not necessarily being able
to generate humor yet but able to
explain why something is funny
so there's uh like puns and all those
kinds of things there's there's good
benchmarks for that but you know if you
tell a joke
there's a lot of unspoken stuff
that we figure out in our head and it
clicks and we understand that it's funny
AI is not able to do that right but it's
not able to generate the joke yet as far
as I've seen I would say that I I mean
just in my experience I would say that
it does because just because of doozy
is literally
I'll give you another weird example it's
writing a diary
of mine from my childhood that is not
accurate it's only partially accurate
based on the stuff that it can pick up
about my life
from the age of like 15 of which there
isn't much but
I guess we're not I don't know that what
we are we're laughing our asses off at
what the at what dudesy is saying well I
would say you're laughing yeah we're
we're laughing our asses off at the
collaboration between the human and and
the Machine there that's a good point
yeah because it's it's basically
introducing absurdity
and uh into the equation and the kind of
absurdity that would together with you
create like hilarious stuff but like on
its own
I guess it is in some way writing
material for you that's funny yeah but
it's very specific to you it can't do
stand up on its own I guess is what I'm
saying that's a good point and that
would be terrifying to see an AI stand
up that can actually read a room come up
with jokes that could complete that
illusion for an audience yeah but I hear
what you're saying that it needs to be a
Confluence of both of those elements and
then as you said like it kind of is it
is it is it's kind of
even though it's just for us and I guess
this is I hadn't really thought about
this up until right now that in that
this company approached us and was like
here's this Ai and it's it's it's a
podcast AI
it's like
it it chose Chad and I for the reasons
that I told you you know it's like
here's two guys that do the podcast
stuff they're actually good friends and
it knows what's going to make us laugh
but what is humor uh to uh when it
reaches its audience but the kind of
stuff that makes other people laugh at
Mad TV all we were doing was it was a
group of actors and writers and and
writer actors and vice versa and
um uh who were at at its best that show
was a group of people making each other
laugh yeah you know and then because we
didn't have the internet we didn't have
the feed the immediate feedback uh we
had a message board or something we had
emails at the very beginning which check
this out people if you have a question
or comment Mad TV or whatever uh and we
would get the emails on a Monday morning
and they would be in a binder or two
like this and they would make their way
around the office and they've got the
emails oh they're in Brian's office and
this is like your poll like your your
this is opinions from people about
different things the emails that yeah
the people like literally just writing
Mad TV like what kind of wasn't the best
well the ones I found most vividly yeah
were fans saying
uh uh you suck yeah you suck like a lot
of that when I first started the show
for real you know because it's a new and
you're a new person it's like who's this
fat bastard I feel like if it's printed
out it hurts more that's a good point
yeah when you're reading it off of paper
and you can literally crunch it up in
your hand but also it was like
um you know I would like to see insert
weird idea from some 14 year old you
know I want to see Stuart do this and
Swan that and um but it was it it's uh
it's a kind of doozy but human it was
yeah it was a very shitty dudes in a in
a Loosely finder but the the
um
the thing about uh the show was we're
trying to make each other laugh and
doozy has found Chad and I who we make
each other laugh but it's joined in and
it's it listen when I finished doing TMP
I didn't really know what I wanted to do
in the podcast space and this thing
found me yeah and it is genuinely
cracking me up anyway I've said enough
about that but I but I do think that
it's figured something out with me it's
a really interesting idea of AI
generating the premise I mean I I do
think in the future AI will be able to
generate
comedy I stand up is obviously the
hardest form because it's ultimately a
lot it has to be live
uh I think I will be able to generate
memes so there's like Steps right and
then it would be able to generate a
Twitter account that people follow
because it's funny like like quips and
stuff like that almost like
um
it's a good example a Conan O'Brien is a
good I think Twitter yeah where it's
like one-liners two liners that kind of
stuff that's in tweeze form and then
eventually
um stand up where the timing and the
chemistry of this the the comedian and
the audience matter and then perfecting
that but I feel like all the information
is there
for to optimize over so I think that's
the future and that forces us to to uh
to contend with what is
what is what do we find compelling and
beautiful about the art form itself so
certainly in art that's being pushed
that question is being raised you know
is is AI
like a fundamentally worse artist than a
human being why do we appreciate art
is that that's something you guys have
talked about what do you think about all
the um Dolly and and um
all the diffusion based methods that are
being generated
that are being that are generating art
now what do you think about that I know
I'll tell you what I think but I also
feel like what I'm saying is I sound
like the guy who didn't like that Bob
Dylan brought in the electric guitar you
know I'm start I I the more I talk to
Chad about it the more I feel like
Grandpa who doesn't want to let go of
this or that or I'm not ready for the
printing press or the Horseless Carriage
but I do feel that the that art is a
connection between people it's it's when
you look at a beautiful painting or a
sculpture you're seeing the humanity of
the person that that brought that
painting to life or sculpted this
incredible piece of art and I think
without the human being there to make it
it's not worth as much just to have it
uh there because the art it's it's it's
Advanced I've seen it Advanced I don't
know you tell me but I feel like just in
the past three or four months I'm just a
consumer as far as that stuff goes I'm
not on the inside I don't get it even
but it's been getting a lot better the
the betas that they're releasing right
absolutely one of the big breakthroughs
I mean Dolly really started it is that
if you train a system on language
it turns out there's a lot of language
and images on the internet but language
is really where it's at in terms of the
depth of human knowledge and so if you
train a system on language it's able to
generate some credible art that was the
Breakthrough with the same kind of
mechanisms they're called Transformers
they're
able to one scaled capture some deep
representation of the language that's on
the internet and so yeah that the the
things has been able to generate to me
look
like it's novel like it doesn't look
like it's mimicking anything it's
looking like it's creating totally new
ideas and they're beautiful and they're
interesting and they're all the ways
that we think
uh that art is interesting the only
thing that's missing is the scarcity
that art often has which is you know it
takes a lot of work from one artist to
create one piece one human being to
create one piece of art and I could just
generate endlessly and that that makes
us appreciate the thing less for some
reason do you have any sort of a similar
opinion that I do that if art doesn't
come from a human being it's inherently
worth a little less yeah I think I don't
know if it's a human being but
the artist matters right
for me and uh
I think some of that has to do with the
world view of the artist and the
backstory the memories that the the life
that led up to this piece of art
the the perspective they Take On The
World the the journey they took to the
world the struggle the triumphs all that
kind of stuff but I think AI systems can
probably have the same
but they we would have to as opposed to
treating it as a one black box
it would have to be an artist that has a
Twitter account and and they have a
consistent personality they have a
consistent Avatar yeah and I think down
the line have something like human
rights but then it really becomes
awfully like a person
well that's terrifying
as much as I dig doozy that's terrifying
I hope but it's terrifying like you know
a lot of things that came with the
internet and the digital age are
terrifying porn is terrifying the mass
like the amount of porn that's online
that was terrifying the uh like you
mentioned Bob Dylan with electric guitar
I would I would compare it more to the
leap from
to uh sort of to the Napster and the um
the spotifyization of Music which is
like you have these it's less about
albums now and it's more about
individual songs and it's much easier to
deliver the songs and it's more about
sort of the engagement of The Listener
versus uh like signing the artist and
like a distribution of the artists and
so on so it's just changing the way
we consume stuff and uh
human interaction is changing into
meaningful interaction even if some of
the entities involved are not human yes
and uh I feel like you know now like as
I say oh I feel like Grandpa who doesn't
want to wait all day for or who enjoys
waiting all day for a baked potato as
anyway Dana Carvey would say it's
another story but uh is that from That's
from the whoever he did this bit on
Saturday Night Live where he's like I'm
a I'm an old man and I like things the
way they used to be you know like if you
wanted a baked potato you wouldn't put
it in the microwave head and then long
story yeah uphill both ways and digging
the potato and baking it all day in a
fire but um uh I'm like that Grandpa now
and I know that you know kids coming
along you see over the past 10 years
like babies literally knowing how to use
an iPhone and it's terrifying and I feel
like uh I'm a little worried because I'm
like are you is the future are the
future generations going to be able to
understand that this is not
not that it's not real it's just I mean
it's as a matter of fact it is real it's
real it's what you perceive
perception is reality and in you know 99
of reality in a lot of ways especially
in a digital world where everyone is now
and then with the metaverse I don't even
want to think about it I don't even I
don't get it
really true I think people will figure
out you see people on like on the train
in public transit and so on they're
staring at their phone
I think you have to remember that the
reason they're staring at their phone I
mean there's a lot of reasons but one of
the reasons is they're connecting with
other human beings they love on that
phone so it is a source of happiness and
joy now social media has a lot of
negative side effects
that we're all talking about and
learning about and I think that means
the next generation of social media
social networks will be better and we'll
learn how to do it in a healthy way
we're just entering a new digital world
that will keep the good stuff and get
rid of the bad stuff oh I hope so that's
really optimistic that sounds great yeah
I mean I mean it because I think that
we're in we're clearly in the wild west
still of the internet and just when you
think you're out of it the internet
proves uh another way that it can be
dangerous and detrimental to uh to
people
um and populations of people and uh it's
terrifying to me it's it it is it's
terrifying let me ask you a bunch of
random questions okay you ready all
right uh if you can be someone else for
a day someone alive today who would you
be
somebody you haven't met
oh that's a really good question it
could be dead yeah let's I change my
mind it could be somebody dead I think
any answer that I have right now would
be something that would be based on some
sort of experience like
you know what I thought was very
interesting was uh last weekend or
whatever the tribute show for Taylor
Hawkins Taylor Hawkins was the drummer
for The Foo Fighters and he passed away
tragically and um uh so that so the Foo
Fighters Dave Grohl and everybody that
got together this concert and you're
watching Dave Grohl
um sing try to sing times like these
right and he's he's breaking up because
he lost his friend his brother and I was
watching that and he's at Wembley
Stadium
uh as I say this I realized that I would
not want to be him uh in that moment but
I am curious what that would be like
that's the ultimate like having to
perform despite something extremely
human happening and uh a stadium full of
people that love Dave Grohl and love
Taylor Hawkins and love
a rock concert and love these artists
that they're getting to see uh up on
stage so much love and so much pain at
the same time I wonder what that would
be like to be
I guess and I think that's just sort of
coming from the root of being a
performer and uh being in front of that
many have you ever had to perform while
some rough stuff is going on in your in
your personal life just mentally yeah
sure was that how tough is that
um I I can come I'm fortunate enough to
be able to compartmentalize uh I I you
know a lot of actors like to use some of
their stuff if you're doing something
that um
and there's a lot of uh you know there's
some acting techniques that sort of
Channel it yeah that which I think is
kind of
I don't know that that's
I don't know for me it's not really the
thing because I think if the writing is
is is great the writing is really good
you don't need to channel much you need
to invest in what's there and the the
what I've always loved about that
illusion is really cracking a scene
getting it to a point where you are
feeling all of it and the most edifying
stuff I've been a part of as as an actor
and uh I would say that it mostly comes
out of dramatic work
is uh is when you're when you actually
feel
the emotions that your character would
feel yeah truly and it's not because
you're pulling from a tragic thing that
happened or a lost loved one or a lost
love or any of that I just did this one
movie where where you know we're doing
the thing and uh it was a wonderful cast
and a great film and and uh um
I'm giving a speech at a wedding and uh
and it really got to us like it got to
me and then one of the other actors came
up and and hugged me in the characters
that we were and but the stakes of his
character and what he's walked into him
the family that he's marrying into and
and what my character my character's
wife want for my wife's sister and this
whole thing and it all became very real
that was a set where the director showed
up to set every day making sure that
emotionally it was a very dramatic film
making sure that emotionally the table
was set for his actors a great crew and
a really nice tight little quick family
as a lot of these movies are uh you you
really love working with these people
and then it's over uh but I I that's
when you feel the drug like it's like
when you're golfing and you you for and
it's on the green you're like oh I get
it now so in the words you can find the
emotion the the word summon the emotion
the Humanity's right there if you read a
great script you're gonna you're gonna
SOB in your living room you know what
the the saddest the toughest thing about
being an actor is for my totally outside
perspective
is from the people I've interacted with
is how intimate that process is between
the group of people that create a thing
that's a movie and then you move on to
the next thing
it's almost it's like a
I don't know I mean that's why people
have relationships on set they get they
fall in love totally so sad I mean like
that's why I think of the acting world
as like
you fall in love with each other
essentially become close friends then
you move on because that's kind of the
process of career you know like the
example I just gave if you're doing it
right yeah there is a certain amount of
that happening but I do still feel like
you can
you gotta compartmentalize it and you've
got to be able to wash it off as soon as
it's over prostitutes say the same thing
so I
swear
I I sometimes I'm in a hurry to
get away from everybody because it's
been it's been very emotional and with
all love and respect to everyone this
was awesome but you get pretty good at
saying goodbye and being like I'll see
you if I see you you have to get good at
that or else you'll never
you'll just be bent up all the time yeah
I saw an actor once while we were doing
this series and we did it for a year and
uh it was it was a lot of fun and it was
a tight little group and then one of the
actors we were doing one of our last
things together we had already shot the
last show and we just had to take some
pictures for uh you know it's like some
publicity pictures or whatever so we're
set up and we're taking our pictures
together and then we move into these
single shots and this actor was finished
and I watched them it's like okay
so-and-so's wrapped and and they said
some goodbyes and stuff and I didn't say
my goodbye because I just did I maybe I
preferred an Irish goodbye I feel like
we've said everything you know what I
mean and this person knows that I Revere
them and they're an idol of mine and
they walked out walked off the sound
sound stage and I literally thought to
myself
that'll be the last time I see that
person and the show did not come back
and that was the last time I don't see
them around doesn't that just break your
heart a little bit but I I know what
she's going back to which is her family
and that's more important than all of
this and that's the thing about a TV
family or a movie Family when you get
together and you're you're a family for
a while you do you are you spend your
days together a lot of times you see the
people that you work with more than you
see your loved ones so in Showbiz it's
no different right and uh yeah you're
doing some you know you got to say words
and every once in a while you gotta kiss
someone or pretend you love them but uh
it it's it's it's just it underscores
how
for me look man my salvation has always
been and I'm I feel so fortunate to have
had it is this kind of kind of chill
boring kind of upbringing that I want
for my kids someday uh and I I can't
wait to get back to my house with my
fiance and the dogs you know until we
have kids and live in a cabin in Canada
somewhere
absolutely I just want to buy some
Landover and aquifer as I like to say
because water will be the new money and
uh and just just make sure that all my
my kids are drinking as much H2O as I am
which is a lot I'm peeing right now as a
matter of fact you need a bathroom
no no not anymore no I'm wearing two
layers it depends don't worry good
um so I did a podcast with Bobby Lee and
he
said he's extremely kind and he said
that he was scared shitless
um to be on on the podcast and he
actually literally took he asked as the
first thing to go and take a dump
because of how scared he was uh so that
leads me to a question what's the
scariest thing you've ever done
or maybe what's the scariest you've ever
been before performance
foreign
I mean I always get a little nervous I
think you're doing it right if you're
still nervous you know are you nervous
today
well no man because this isn't a
performance I'm being completely genuine
yeah you're wearing a suit yeah that was
I feel like that makes you nervous where
it makes me nervous listen I hate
wearing a [ __ ] collar if you're
watching this on YouTube look to see me
just this is yeah I'm constantly doing
it's like I'm doing like a cheap Rodney
Dangerfield but I am truly when you move
your head it kind of makes it seem like
you're like a mobster who's pissed off a
little bit Yeah you [ __ ] crossed me
one last time you suck you know yeah
it's mutt yeah I think it's the first
time I dug a hole Jesus
um no but truly I hate having a a caller
I should I can't wait to just wear
pajamas in that [ __ ] uh cabin or
nothing at all walk around Bobby Lee
style yeah
um this most scared I've been before a
performance
I can't pinpoint I can't pinpoint
anything I I
you know when I was a kid right I like I
said I was fortunate enough to start
acting as a teen and stuff uh
professionally and I just remember my
first gig and I remember saying my
handful of lines in the bathroom mirror
the night before going
this might be my only [ __ ] shot
you're not gonna get me I'm gonna be
solid
and I I when I'm if I'm worried about
something I will rehearse it and
rehearse it and rehearse it as an actor
until it's impossible for me not to get
a take at least that I'm 100 if not 95
maybe percent happy with and the rest
for me is Letting Go which is hard
because I can be a real
perfectionist I always want another I
always want to do it a little better
that's what's great about podcasting is
one take and you're done there's no
takes
um you're just talking and it's over and
you're doing some silly stuff and I'll
I'll you know can you say that part
again about why podcasting is great
podcasting is great yeah because it's
one take and it's over it's just it's it
what I said it again ah [ __ ]
um I see what you did uh and I'd yeah I
fell right for it but um I'm playing
checkers and you're playing chess that's
your problem
you know but still when we do the
podcast we'll like finish and I'll look
over at chatting them that one thing
that I did wasn't that fun he's like
shut up man just yeah it doesn't matter
it's a [ __ ] hang we're just we're
hanging with our friends out there
that's what we're doing so that anxiety
is there the self-criticism or whatever
that is that voice I say sorry after
takes I'll I'll always finish a take and
go and I've had director to the
detriment of myself yeah I've had
directors be like stop doing that yeah
because I'll like finish taking then I
also have like the the will face and I'm
just like I'll finish it and cut and I'm
making a face right now like I smelled
something but that's what I'll do I'll
literally be like ah because I just
I I I look at I look at what I do in the
pure sense as
I think I think a lot of people want to
be good at something I've only the only
thing I've ever really wanted to be good
at is being an actor and that's that's
the only thing of course I want to be a
good person I want to be a good partner
to my fiance I want to have kids and be
a the father that I had and and want to
be the parent that I had for my parents
who were [ __ ] amazing wonderful
people and uh there's all those things
that's all that's all you know you
should want all those things but as far
as doing a thing like what is my what is
my trade you know I want to be
really good at it my my um my parents
grew up in Napoli in Italy right and I
say Napoli because I'm Italian and so my
grandfather and my mom's side my Nono
Pepe he was a plumber and he was also uh
he was also like a handyman yeah like
people would bring him like you know
like the old Chianti bottle with like
with the woven bottom part like people
would bring him like a broken bottle be
like hey you know Joseph can you fix
this and he'd be saying like you're
telling the backstory of Mario that's
not actually your family life yeah but
okay yeah yeah and so he just said he
would fix a bottle and give it back
someone and he was a he was a really
good plumber my mom used to always say
that guy was an amazing he was a great
he took pride in that yeah I always feel
like you know
there's what you set out to do as an
idealistic little teenager I want to be
like so and so and I want to you know
hear my Big Dreams and stuff and I can't
believe that I'm still in the business
okay that's first of all let me say that
right now I got I do I can't believe it
but what I've re what I really
I I it's the one thing that it's like I
can't give up on a take you know I need
it to be as good as I can possibly get
it and I don't really know why that is
outside of wanting to be good at
something when you open the Yellow Pages
if I'm a plumber I'm not you know I I'm
not Roto-Rooter like I'm not the guy
with the big full page ad but I'm also
not
you know AAA Abacus brothers or whatever
like the shitty one yeah I I would like
to Hope
that just and I'm saying this with with
pride for what I do I'm not trying to
say here's my standing or where I want
to be in the [ __ ] business that's not
what I mean I mean that I want to be
good at it you know we all hello
Friedman Enterprises
so that's the hotel phone
you have some fruit
some Celeste fruit no do you want some
sliced fruit I'm all good no we're good
thank you so much
all right all right bye-bye it's always
a fruit plate
everyone's always trying to hand you a
fruit plate in life you know
if that was actually like the CIA and
they were actually saying something else
and this is I'm just saying fake stuff
about you want some fruit yeah I want
some fruit then all of a sudden there's
the Red Dot on my head and yeah and the
ceiling disappears and the the ca was
like wrap it up wrap it up wrap it up
wrap it up you jump out the window and
there's a helicopter waiting uh what
were we talking about uh food distracted
me so oh the do you want to be that's
one of the other page ad I want to be
the guy on the second or third page yeah
where it's like you're not gonna you
know you're not gonna pay what that guy
charges you but we're not gonna I'm not
gonna charge you with this loser charge
you know I want to break down the middle
and the work is guaranteed that's kind
of what I want to you know it's the one
thing that I that I've been fortunate
enough to be doing my whole life and
that I want to uh
that I want to be good at you know
everyone wants to be good at something
if you're fortunate enough to be able to
do what you love is a job I mean my God
I'm so I'm I again I can't believe I get
to do it I just want to be good at it so
that I can [ __ ] you know die someday
and go uh I tried not to give up on a
take and I you know and I will rehearse
it still in the in the bathroom mirror
the night before if I have to
yeah but I still I have that soft
critical voice I just
uh after every part after this podcast
I'll probably be like you
you're boring why are you so boring
and I just gave a lecture at MIT I was
like
I'm I got so much love from people
there's such beautiful people and I just
remember walking home
just feeling like we like I wasted
everybody's time you know and then it's
it's I don't know what that is I don't
you know I I do hope that that's a voice
that won't destroy me you know like
that's really human of you to admit that
because people don't wanna
they wouldn't assume that of course from
you or anything that I mean you've got
A A large group of students in there
listening to you and feeling the way and
thinking what they think of you uh so
that's really interesting to hear you
um admit that but it's also I would
expect nothing else you have to be able
to it's such a I mean you're a human
[ __ ] being and I'm trying to figure
out if that you know some people that
might hear that that would say well
that's a problem you have to fix and I
think that that might be just who I am
yeah because I'm not you know I've been
very very fortunate not to have chemical
you know like the depression where I get
into a dark place like it gets stuck in
the in the downward spiral it's it's
usually a thing that lasts you write it
out and you and then after a good
night's sleep you're back to uh back to
your happy self so I think
I have to try to figure that that out is
that just part of the creative process
being a creative human in this world
I've found any other way I'm always
kicking myself take that Duty you can't
you can't the the you're not gonna be
human until you feel some despair yeah
criticism absolutely hate the [ __ ] that
you're doing sometimes
uh what small act of kindness were you
once shown that you will never forget do
you know there's something jumped to
mind where somebody just did something
that made you smile
did you uh feel connected to the rest of
humanity
yeah yeah
lots of things you know
um but I remember my niece one time one
of my nieces
we were in her neighborhood and she was
like she might have been
five or six at the time they're all
adults now my brother and sister are
older than me and the kids are all the
youngest is 22. and uh yeah anyway one
of my nieces she was just she had ice
cream we went out and we got ice cream
walking around the neighborhood her
neighborhood and uh
she said something to me that I don't
think she understands how much it meant
at the time but she goes she goes people
love you here you know that and she
doesn't know where here is she's five
years old but she was just looking at
the kids playing in the park and the
people walking their dogs and everyone
just people love you here you know that
but she didn't know how much I needed to
hear that at that point which was really
heavy for me I'll never forget it I've
never told her that oh well and anytime
you get
a little something from people
especially in a tear your ass out city
like La where yeah somebody has any
[ __ ] time for you when someone can
slow it down and say something yeah you
know
I try I I I saw this actor once in my
grocery store that I go to who made me
laugh so [ __ ] hard in this one movie
and every time I see this clip I still
laugh and I'm I am kind of shy you know
uh personally but so he uh he was
walking by he was walking out and I was
walking in and like oh that's that guy
and I did not stop to
just let him know how great I thought he
was in this film and I always kind of
regretted it you know what I mean so as
hard as it is and sometimes I still
don't if I see someone that has done
something in in you know in any way it
doesn't have to be in show business or
anything like that a try you know I'll
try and say hey that's that's really
good you know what I mean
um because to get that from someone can
mean
a lot you know at a certain time in life
when you need it yeah they can make a
big difference I mean I sorry to uh take
it back to my new girlfriend the
waitress oh yeah yeah but she there's
something about her saying sweetheart
yeah I was in a pretty low place for
some reason mentally and it's just that
that basically human kindness was nice
yeah yeah yeah yeah I hear you I was at
a restaurant in uh New York recently and
I was shooting something and my fiance
was able to fly in for a week and uh but
she was back at the hotel and it's like
I felt like I was cheating on her
because there was this nice waitress at
this barbecue place I went to and uh
first of all my fiance would not like me
eating any greasy sugary barbecue so I
felt like I was cheating on we'll edit
this out and put delicious vegan food
over it but the waitress was one of
these you know she was this the kind of
server who's like hey hun you say hey
sweetie like blah blah but like so chill
and at ease it in the middle of a part
of New York that's really you know kind
of [ __ ] pretentious and you know and
everybody but
sweet people [ __ ] way better people
oh my God here but uh you know I uh I
know that but you know it's part of New
York and whatever I'm there working and
people I'm like you know I'm trying to
impress one another and uh she was she
even had some sort of an accent that was
not
didn't feel like an Atlantic uh American
accent uh yeah although those yeah
servers that say sweetheart and hun yeah
that's what we need from AI we need that
that Jetson server every once in a while
just calls you sweetheart yeah what uh
comforts you on bad days oh man is there
little sources of comfort
small things they do that kind of make
you feel good like for Bobby that would
be a little Skyrim
a little stroll through Skyrim well I
I've been a line of coke or what yeah I
dilute some coke into Whiskey in the
morning like Stevie Ray Vaughan and then
I didn't know that yeah yeah oh my gosh
interesting yeah it didn't last too long
weird
um well his music will last forever all
right see there you go
for me if I
I'm kind of a homebody so if I
the the point at which I smoke just a
little bit of pot and then go like
lay down on the couch and
and perhaps if my fiance is kind of
nodding off or she's just like looking
at her phone and I sneakily turn on some
wrestling okay because I grew up
watching wrestling and that stuff it's
the Skyrim effect I mean yeah you want
to talk about a complete escape this
stuff makes no sense in the world it's
an art form that is so uniquely weird
but at the same time so
everyone when it's good everyone is
invested in the illusion even the
audience they cheer the good guys they
boo the bad guys so if I'm like that and
then I got our two cute little dogs
there and I'm annoying my little dog
lulio and you know trying to kiss him
right on the [ __ ] mouth and I've had
a little bit of pot and the dog's like
stop the pot's not good for me
um of course don't ever blow pot into
your dog's face that's that's a small
Comfort I guess that's a handful of
things no that moment painted that was
like a little painting what about you
you're not supposed to do this well well
you're not supposed to do this that's a
good question uh yeah it's it's a it's a
tough question
um
I would say
I would say programming robots I uh
there's bringing to life actually
programming at all and so I don't know
if you how familiar you are with
programming but you write
some text on a page right on a screen
and it's brought to life like it does
something and and
that's kind of that's a really tiny
version of maybe having a child like you
you created something that is now living
yeah in some smaller big way with
embodied robots that are legged robots
that's especially clear and for some
reason that's a source of
comfort for me that that the the power
of programming but also the Elegance of
programming just the whole thing it's a
source uh yeah it's a source of
Happiness there's so many things I've
been very blessed with enjoying anything
like that's part of the struggle I have
in life is that the simple stuff is a
source of a lot of happiness for me
which leads to a lot of laziness
so I have to like give myself artificial
deadlines I have to be freaking out on
purpose in order to be productive in
this world at all you seem like an
extremely beautiful busy guy no no I am
but because I'm constantly creating
artificial
stress and deadlines and all that kind
of stuff otherwise I would just sit
there looking at a tree happy I'm truly
happy with everything
that's awesome yeah gee whiz that's not
well that's the line of coke in the in
the in the whiskey in the morning that's
that that's the thing that uh
breakfast shake by the way one of my
most favorite guitars I play guitar too
that's the source oh yeah I have seen
you play some guitar that's awesome
who's the greatest wrestler of all time
greatest in-ring performer of all time
is Brett the Hitman Hart what's the
difference in Ring versus well there's
you know there's many facets to the art
form a lot of people are great on the
mic but they're not so great once they
get in the ring a lot of people have all
the uh the Showmanship and stuff but
then they're not necessary it's a
wonderful package but then they get to
the ring or they open their mouth and
there's nothing going on so who's the
greatest in-ring performer I think the
greatest in ring is Bret Hart I don't
think there's anyone better than than
Bret the Hitman Hart uh uh what makes
them so good
well he I think I had an action figure
of him of him in Russia and we didn't
know what the hell that was oh sure yeah
I was just a guy in pink tights uh he
everything makes sense every single
thing is rooted in the thing that just
happened and everything that he does is
to set up what he's going to do uh they
call it and I'm just a wrestling nerd
but the wrestlers I guess call it ring
psychology
um the things that you have to do to to
make it seem like you're you're
suffering or you're coming from behind
or whatever and then also just the
physicality of it he does it at a he
would do it at a 100 miles an hour and
never hurt anybody uh although
you know I I also love uh the every you
know the greatest wrestler of all time
everyone says and they're right is Rick
Flair Nature Boy Ric Flair everyone says
this yeah I think if you know what
you're talking about
um because he's the best on the mic he's
the he's also incredible in the ring and
then for me the sentimental favorite
which we've actually on dudesy Chad had
sort of a uh Charlie rose-ask interview
with me about this my fascination with
Hulk Hogan because to me just he was
Superman I was a little kid and I saw
him and that's imprinted but yeah see
this is like asking me who my favorite
child is right so uh The Rock when The
Rock was yeah I mean the Rocks the rock
yeah yeah I mean Hulk Hogan is
um
he's the weirdest one right for me from
the outside super weird that I don't
know what what that is exactly it's
everything's weird about him yeah he's
got the ball head like he would proudly
have this bald head with long hair the
handlebar mustache in this ketchup and
mustard you know tights which he says he
credits McDonald's with the tights he
literally does he says that the the red
and yellow came from Angelo poffo who's
Randy Macho Man Savage and Lanny paffo's
dad who's a wrestler and a promoter he
said that he saw him wearing yellow and
you know he's a Tampa guy so he had that
brown skin and the hair and everything
so he's like oh that's what I want to do
and also the brand recognition of like
well I should do it like McDonald's
literally and he's a big you know
swollen muscular uh guy with tanned
brown skin screaming at me to eat my
vitamins and stuff when I'm eight years
old that was extremely uh yeah he's like
Superman I but I know there's a person
behind that guy yeah you know what do
you mean well yeah he's Terry Bollea the
dude who you know
does whatever the [ __ ] he does with his
life you know what I mean yeah
complicated life yeah I guess okay to be
him yeah yeah maybe you should change
the the dudes the uh colors to Yellow
right red yellow it's currently orange
and um
boy sky blue yeah it's like a nice sky
blue
what advice
since you're wearing a suit I feel like
you're qualified to give advice what
advice would you give to young people
High School College about how to have a
career they can be proud of
or how to have a life they can be proud
of I mean you have to listen to your gut
all the time that's the only that's the
compass that we have is listening to
your gut what did your gut tell you this
is is that was that originally the dream
of being an actor yeah for me your
parents support that at all I had the
advantage of having parents who were
immigrants so they didn't really know a
lot about what you you just made [ __ ] up
you just made sure like yeah of course
I'm studying and I'm skipping school to
go do auditions and stuff no I I just
kind of feel like you know and I know it
was different from my older siblings
because my parents had just shown up in
Canada I was born like 10 years later
um uh you can get away with some things
and you can actually you know I think my
parents
they wanted us to they didn't have a
whole lot to tell us about what to do
um they weren't going to do that with us
because they're in this brand new world
and there's all these possibilities and
but there was a
there was something that they I feel
like they had to do which was tell us to
do what we love if you love doing it do
it
and um I feel like that's really served
me and what I would tell young people is
if you can find something you love and
nowadays with the internet and finding
other people that you know it's not like
you need to find
a lot of people anymore you just need to
find the people that dig what you dig
and if you can make a career out of
doing something that you love that's
been said it's
it's a good thing you know how long did
you did it take you to figure out that
you really love
um acting you know because sometimes you
have a dream and then you meet the dream
meets reality right yeah and then the
reality might be much less Pleasant and
much darker than the Dream well the
reality is Less Pleasant you know and
and there are things that happen uh
during an experience of shooting
something that that you could take or
leave right but the the you know the the
part where you're on set and you've
you know you've rehearsed for a minute
or whatever at least you know where
you're supposed to stand and you know
all your lies show up knowing everything
knowing what you're going to do and uh
what you aim to do and um those moments
make it all worth it when you're you
know not sound like a douchebag but
between act you know action and cut
that's the stuff that is uh that can
that makes me that has me continuing to
do do what I do aside from the fact that
it's like I don't know how to do
anything else you think you'll ever do
like a dramatic like like a mob movie
yeah like the one of the inside game I
was just talking about is this other
movie I just did it was a little while
ago called American woman that was very
heavy
um and uh I love doing dramatic work I
love it I love it yeah and I played that
the in inside game it was kind of a it
you know it was a there was a mob
element and uh
the fella was well you know the stories
here or there with regard to how deep uh
into them but well he was a bookie he
was just running money you know doing he
was making a lot of money for a lot of
people and he figured out how to you
know cook it with this dude
um who was an NBA ref and and it's a
very interesting documentary the thing
that just uh Untold under the untold
series they cover it but getting to play
that guy that was a that was a that was
a gas for me because he's like a he was
a you know there was a lot of unsavory
stuff and he's definitely the guy the
character in the movie
who is the wild card and and and you
don't want to necessarily mess with them
and I got this I remember this fellow
who is a real guy
speaking to him it was just bizarre to
hear
like I said to him he was a little
concerned about this and that like hey
you know you say whatever the [ __ ] you
want in your movie I got my book and I
got this other [ __ ] deal but he goes
you know I didn't do this and I didn't
do that and I'm like yeah all right I
got you and he goes I'm telling you like
I'm talking to you one-on-one I did not
do this I did okay I'm just [ __ ] tell
you do whatever the [ __ ] you want with
your movie but this is what's up and I
said you ever seen Good Fellas he's like
I [ __ ] love that movie because he
like I said he did some unsavory [ __ ]
and I go you remember the scene where uh
where you know the guy the neighbor
Lorraine bracco's neighbor was you know
made her uncomfortable and was touching
on her and she she goes to Ray Liotta
and he goes where the [ __ ] does this guy
live and then he go and remember and he
walks across the street and Pistol whips
the dude you
hear me yeah don't you
[ __ ] great scene he goes I love that
scene I go that's you so you're doing
[ __ ] that we know is terrible but we
love you he goes all right I got it and
then I said there's this one scene I
explained the scene to him where the one
of the Mobsters uh tough guys was in the
window of the car and Jimmy my character
is very coked up at the time and he's
hemorrhaging money here and there and
making bad bets because he's getting
sloppy and this guy wants to bug him
about some Jets Giants bet or something
I'm like telling you [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] do it he's like yeah well
the [ __ ] Giants and in the scene
Jimmy my character grabs him by the by
the lapels and just smashes his face
against the the the the roof of the car
and I I say this to to Jimmy and he goes
oh yeah I would have done that that's
not a [ __ ] big deal I wonder also the
interaction I wonder what the filming of
um probably my favorite gambling movie
is
um casino with with Joe Pesci and De
Niro like when they're out in the desert
yelling at each other I wonder how many
takes that is like because they I I
don't I don't know how scripted that is
I mean it probably is a little bit but
like I I don't think you can script the
performance that Joe Pesci does don't
yeah like I [ __ ] brought you here
yeah he's just like pointing at the that
that that energy and they're standing
there and their friendships De Niro is
like like that that whole thing and then
in the pet yeah like that that energy
what is that I mean they must they
somehow find it together you could tell
me that that was one take and I believe
you you could tell me that that was
seven takes and I would believe I bet
you all the takes had that energy like
they were playing with it right they
were they're playing with that the the
this yeah I mean they they took on
a real
personality in those scenes and really
carried them forward I mean it's just a
brilliant brilliant performance it
doesn't get like comedies like mob
movies probably don't get enough credit
either
because it's seen as like mob movies
don't get enough credit not in the
Oscars I mean like that oh yeah yeah
yeah because it seems like a Trope it's
like given a western uh it's got to be a
hell of a western or whatever because
it's like an old Hollywood Trope yeah no
I that scene is so great because they're
never there at the height of their
friendship in a way and they're also
pretty much about to let go of it and
become enemies and both things are
happening at the same time and and Pesci
drives him out to the desert and if I
remember correctly
De Niro's character eighth Ace rostin
Rothschild he says I I gave myself 50 50
whether I'm coming back yeah it's such a
good scene
usually my prospects of coming back from
the desert would be 90 to 10 or
something like that but now it was this
time I wasn't sure and this the car
driving really fast and then Joe Pass is
like you [ __ ] you like whatever
he was doing yeah a Jew I think of
course is anti-Semitism yeah we're not
between friends
who gives a [ __ ] all that kind of stuff
yeah I mean brilliant brilliant
performances so yeah I I can understand
why you love the art and putting it all
out there and yeah it's fun it's fun and
it's still fun it's still crazy fun if I
go a while without getting a gig
you know if I go a minute then I end up
and I work on something I'm like it is
like it's like oh I've been thirsty for
this like I actually am really so happy
even if it's something where it's like
you know the the the things where this
was a pain in the ass and that or
whatever you're on the road doing
something and you know anything whatever
you lost your luggage or whatever the
heck you've got going on in your
day-to-day life uh that everyone brings
uh to work and tries to let go of
once we're doing the scene oh man it's
the best but you know that said uh
you're a great actor but I just think I
speak for a lot of people that you're
also there's a Charisma to you that's
great to reveal in raw form in different
podcasts
in dudesy ten minute pod just as a guest
and podcast it's always really fun to
watch you cheers the way you have fun
the way you think
uh the raw the raw will assassin which
is a nice complement to your kind of
acting that's really sweet yeah cheers
well you know look you said uh you know
uh you're making that face I'm making
that face I'm making that after the take
face no I love doing stuff off the cuff
that's kind of you to say and I dig
I really do dig doing stuff in front of
an audience because I love seeing I
don't give it to myself very often if
I'm doing even if I'm you know I've done
a bunch of multi-camera sitcoms and
stuff Mad TV was shot in front of a live
studio audience you like that energy I
love it but I can only hear them you
can't see them because of the lights
like it is in in a lot of uh
performances and I would imagine
with stand up it's you know you see the
first couple rows
um I've done a I do this character that
does stand up and I used to take him out
and do things with him and do little
bits here and there I haven't done it in
like four or five years I think did
Bobby say that character opened up for
Bobby yeah but he said I have to do it
as myself too I think in that podcast
he's like okay you're gonna come with me
and open for me in Brea what you have to
do as yourself did that ever happen it
did and I did the character uh uh you
know who's a character I came up with on
10 Minute Podcast he's just this
comedian right he calls himself an open
mic veteran you know he's been doing
open mics forever and so I did it at it
opening up for Bobby and he's like you
have to do some of it as yourself so I
just kind of did this bit where I would
do some of his jokes and then I would
take Lee Leon silly I got a [ __ ] wig
on and I take the wig off and I go and
as myself I start explaining it hello my
name is will see the reason that it's
funny is because uh Arnold
Schwarzenegger is always he's in these
movies and he's got the thick Austrian
accent but he's like you know my name is
Ben Williams I'm a I'm a cop from
Colorado no you're not uh and it doesn't
make sense as the comedian character
that I'm doing because that character
doesn't do impersonations okay carrying
on and then I put the wig back on and go
back into this dumb thing yeah and uh I
don't think it was very good but Bobby
required it in order for me to open for
him he's like you're not [ __ ] doing
it so I'm not gonna get up on stage and
not do we agreed I'll do it but
um having been up there just in you know
whatever I've done it like a dozen
[ __ ] times so we're not a bunch of
times right like nothing uh and you know
these comedians that go up every night
sometimes two times a night it's I I do
I will say I love performing in front of
people when I get the chance but it's
it's uh it's a specific thing that that
uh that I I just I just I don't know I
gotta go back to this it's like the
providing value yeah you know I think
great stand-ups are [ __ ] incredible
I'll I'll go you know when I've gone and
watch stand up you know there's your
friend you're going to see but then
there's this other person who really
speaks to you you know what I mean and
if you like one comedian a night that's
a lot because a a
a comedy club is like a [ __ ] crazy
restaurant where there's no menu and
it's like yeah what would you like
there's nothing else like that there's
like you don't go to like a like music
Place well what do we got here we got
Christian metal and there's some World
music and then there's a reggae thing
and it's all rammed in together
or you don't go to a restaurant
I'd love a nice steak cool first here's
a bowl of fruit loops and then then we
got you a crudite and then this is our
Sushi Tower and well what about the
steak oh the steak's coming and then
blah blah oh no the steak got bumped so
there's no steak but here's a [ __ ]
shitty store-bought cheesecake yeah you
know and that's what comedians are up
against when they go into a place it's
like I don't pair well with the poached
salmon you know I'm chicken fingers I
already I already am chicken fingers so
you know these great comedians that are
able to go up on a night where poached
salmon goes up and then it's like [ __ ]
I'm you are all so spicy I got some
kicked to me for me
even going to open mics it could be a
wonderful Escape yeah I mean just
laughing laughing together with others
it can make you I don't know it just
feels really good when we've done like
you know like and I hope to do it with
doozy but like live podcasts are fun in
front of groups of people and you know
you talk to them afterwards and and take
some pictures and man they are ah they
forgot what the [ __ ] they got going on
yeah and a lot of them got to go back to
work the next day it's Wednesday or
Thursday you know no it's it's a lot of
value I'm fortunate enough to be busy
doing my own [ __ ] what's the meaning
of life was awesome
uh what is it why why are we here why
why why
was it uh the meaning of life wasn't
didn't they explain it at the end of
meaning of life I think it was Michael
Palin that said uh try to get a walk-in
uh be nice to neighbors uh eat enough
fiber wasn't that the fiber fibers part
of it yeah I think it's I think it's
nutrition I have Ebola brand in the
morning and uh don't take yourself too
seriously
yeah no well no one gets out alive I
think is the Hermann Hesse one of my
favorite writers he's a Nobel Prize
winner
um in in a in a book called Steppenwolf
says learn what is to be taken seriously
and laugh at the rest oh that's awesome
what's the percentage Distribution on
that so how much of life should you take
seriously and then how much do you just
laugh at oh man if you can laugh at
everything you're you're winning yeah
but that's almost impossible I think
that there's there's uh and also could
be quite irresponsible to do that
I take things I take a lot of things way
too seriously I know that uh I do I do I
really do people will be in part
surprised by that but I think that
radiates from you really yeah I do I
take things way too [ __ ] seriously
sometimes but um yeah you're gonna
loosen the neck up yeah but uh no I
think that's that's really good that's
that's really good stuff it I don't know
what the percentage is to have a good
life or or or or a happy healthy life
but
you know for me the meaning of life is
getting to live it as long as you hope
to that's nice and
um and when you're when you lose someone
or or if perhaps you're faced with your
own mortality I think that puts that
into perspective and uh
but I you know get lots of vibe get lots
of fiber uh be nice to everybody and uh
yeah don't take things too seriously
it's a good it's a good one our minds
are [ __ ]
big weird
it's a big weird shitty [ __ ] bucket
of [ __ ] that's trying to get you to
think horrible [ __ ] about yourself all
the time shitty bucket of [ __ ] shitty
bucket of [ __ ] she has a book I never
read but I read the title and it's good
words to live by which is uh don't sweat
the small stuff and it's all small stuff
that's another way was that Dr Phil
wasn't Dr Phil I don't know but I think
the conclusion is also has fiber that's
part of it I think it all that all ties
it together and in the end of course
just put love out there in the world
I think that's a pretty good way what
would you say is the meaning of life put
love on the world I would say love yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's a it's a long
conversation what that really means uh
but I'm sure robots are involved yeah
well let me tell you I feel a little
safer knowing that someone who has a
hand in
bringing these robots to the masses as
you do has that uh opinion of of love
and how important it is I think that's
great because uh otherwise it's going to
be that uh [ __ ] scene from T2 where
uh Linda Hamilton's holding on to the
the fence and getting all of her flesh
blown off of her skeleton before the
rest of hers is wiped away because this
Skynet [ __ ] anyway I'm just terrified of
doozy all the time that's why I think
that they will uh dude's in the wrong
hands can do a lot of damage that's why
Chad and I need to con do our best to
control it I need to travel back in time
and murder Chad
I think yeah that's yeah that's the only
way it's been said I don't know why you
need to travel back in time but well uh
I will murder him today but I think
they'll be very suspicious my nefarious
plans for Chad involve going back to
tomorrow and planning for yesterday and
then and hopefully doozy will give me
the answer there with what what it is to
do with uh Chad's frozen body if I gotta
drive it out too if I got to take my uh
you know if I gotta get get a hold of
like a one of those uh Tesla mom Vans
and uh shove my garage freezer in it and
plug it in and shove Chad in there drive
out to Arizona and deliver him under a
mountain or wherever the [ __ ] this place
is and say Here's this dog tag what does
this get me and they're like ah it's
gonna be uh 300 bucks do you have a do
you take AMEX no and I'd be like ah [ __ ]
and I'll just dump them somewhere
breaking bad stuff
well I would like to thank you and the
what is it the Canadian International
agency apparel committee for National
apparel I can't wait uh for the sneakers
from Duty I can't wait for all the uh
all the uh the podcasts
uh that AI can and all the trouble can
get you and so I'm a huge fan of yours
it's a huge honor that you would talk
with me today well this has been amazing
cheers pal likewise and I'm happy to be
here man cheers
oh that was three hours dude holy [ __ ]
what
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Will Sasso to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description and now let
me leave you with some words from John
Candy one of Will's favorite actors
I think I may have become an actor to
hide from myself
you can escape into a character
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time